Guten Morgen Linus.
Sendung fängt gleich an. Hast du deine umgemacht.
Ich muss nur mal gucken, ob ich das jetzt darf oder nicht oder ob ich mir jetzt den Mund zuhalten muss.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundsechsundvierzig vom vierundzwanzigsten November zwanzigzweiundzwanzig ja und äh hier berichten wir heute live aus,
Katar.
Ja, das ist ein Problem. Mhm. Alles zensiert, alles kaputt zensiert. Man darf nix darf man mehr sagen.
Schon gar nicht mehr liebe und so. Ist schlimm, nee.
Ich finde es der Gastgeber nicht mag.
Nee.
Das ist doch endlich endlich ist die WM da, wo ich sie immer haben wollte.
Er macht auf jeden Fall keinen besonders eleganten Eindruck und sie sie handlen es auch noch ziemlich schlecht. Das muss man dazu sagen. Also das finde ich immer so,
handelt äh glaube ich die ganze Sendung heute von so von so großen fails
die dazu auch noch extrem schlecht gehandelt werden so nicht nicht nur an sich schon alles äh scheiße läuft, sondern äh es wird auch noch wirklich in äh einer Formidabel miserabelen Art und Weise dargeboten und ähm
Da ist die Fußballweltmeisterschaft gerade ganz weit vorne.
Ja ist doch äh aber ich wirklich, ich kann nur sagen, ich kein also es ist bisher also in meinen Augen beste WM. Stört am wenigsten bisher.
Stimmt alle Dingse.
Wirklich fünf von sieben.
Scheint gar nicht da zu sein, ne.
Ja, echt. Hat überhaupt nicht wehgetan.
Ist halt auch noch Deutschland verloren, gleich zu Anfang des das hilft natürlich schon mal extrem.
Könnte für mich nicht besser laufen.
Das äh freut mich für dich. Das freut mich für dich, Linus. So, aber da wir heute über die großen äh Katastrophen äh der Welt sprechen wollen, wie sonst ja eigentlich auch immer, ähm.
Das aber ganz viel mit Geld zu tun hat, haben wir uns heute äh mal wieder den Daniel eingeladen. Daniel, Daniel Kröger, hallo, herzlich willkommen bei Logbuck Netzpolitik.
Hallo Tim, hallo Linus.
Genau, wir hatten dich ja schon ähm zweimal? Zweimal am Sta.
Jetzt äh habe ich natürlich mir nicht rausgeschrieben, wann denn das der Fall war, aber das ist schnell recherchiert äh am Januar einundzwanzig, also schon fast zwei Jahre her, echt krass,
mit dem schönen Namen, der Schwarze-Block fährt jetzt Tesla. Haben wir schon mal eine schöne Andeutung.
Jetzt nicht mehr, ne.
Auf Twitter, so die Tesla sind ganz schön angepisst, da ist die eine 40.000 Euro Mager Mütze haben.
Und äh genau und dann noch mal knapp ein Jährchen äh davor auch haben wir über äh Auswirkungen der Coronakrise gesprochen und so.
Wenn das Abendland untergeht, dann.
Immer wenn irgendwas untergeht, dann äh dann müssen wir unbedingt dadrüber reden. Letztes Mal war's ja
GameStop und irgendwie so dieses ganze Verhalten von äh Aktienmärkten und auch Tradingbörsen und äh wenn das alles so von den Nutzern äh gesteuert wird, inwiefern, dann die Märkte auseinander äh gehen,
Ja und jetzt haben wir wieder zu äh gleich mehrere Sachen, die wir da äh besprechen wollen, um's vielleicht vorwegzunehmen. Also wir werden uns heute mal auf dieses ganze FTX
Drama äh konzentrieren einerseits und auf das äh Twitterdrama andererseits, was wir hier auch letzte Woche schon aufgegriffen haben.
Würde ich sagen, legen wir doch einfach äh gleich mal los oder müssen wir dich nochmal kurz vorstellen, Daniel.
Könnt ihr gerne.
Ja, also äh kannst du auch selber.
Selber machen. Warum sollen wir das denn immer machen.
Also also du bist in Finanz Dingen unterwegs, ne? Du bist äh managst ja selber einen Vor und du verfolgst Märkte. So, das würde ich mal so vor allem voranstellen.
Ja genau, also ich mache das mittlerweile seit 20 Jahren. Ähm Hintergrund, glaube ich, hat er schon mal gesagt, äh bin ich ja Informatiker, das heißt äh technische Themen sind mir jetzt nicht äh,
ganz so fremd. Ähm genau den Fonds, meinen eigenen, den ich äh jetzt seit drei Jahren Manages ja sehr sehr konzentriert, also wenig Unternehmen,
hat viel mit Digitalisierung zu tun, also Softwarebereich, Chipbereich, kann aber auch Medizinbereich sein,
pendel relativ viel auf der Welt, was ich zwischen San Francisco oder USA und Europa hin und her ein bisschen Asien um Unternehmen natürlich vorzutreffen. Klar, da kriegt man natürlich viel mit. Ich denke auch, wenn wir gleich über Twitter reden, da kann man auch ein paar Anekdoten mit einbauen aus der Vergangenheit und ähm.
Die waren ja in dem Fond drin, ne.
Ja stimmt, das hatte ich dir mal erzählt, genau. Ich habe sie, dann zähle ich jetzt zum Schluss, zum Schluss verkauft, äh genau bei vierundfünfzig.
Äh genau, das äh und dann natürlich dadurch, dass du dich mit Trading und solchen Sachen auseinandersetzt, äh dann natürlich auch bei FT FTX klar, dass äh dass wir da mit dir drüber sprechen wollen
und äh ja ich muss also ich muss tatsächlich sagen, diese ganze FTX-Sache ich halte zwar internationale Vorträge
Das ist alles Betrüger sind, aber diese Betrüger, die kannte ich noch gar nicht.
Man könnte mir das jetzt wahrscheinlich als äh als mangelhafte äh Kenntnis des Untersuchungsgegenstandes durchaus äh vorwerfen. Ich weiß nur, dass dieser Sam Bankman Freed hm.
Im Effective Alltraurison Movement war. Daher kannte ich ihn dann doch, ich hatte das äh in einem anderen Podcast schon mal von von ihm gehört, ja ähm aber vielleicht kannst du uns ja zu Beginn mal irgendwie erklären,
was FTX überhaupt ist.
Also wir haben in in im Logbuch ja viel über was Kryptowährungen sind und so gesprochen aber ich glaube so diesen gesamten Bereich.
Und dann noch komplexere Finanzkonstrukte. Den haben wir hier im weitesten Sinne noch gar nicht erklärt.
Ich meine, das, was was grundsätzlich da passiert ist.
Passiert in der Finanzgeschichte häufig. Also ich meine das nur die Geschwindigkeit, die die ist beeindruckend, wie schnell so ein Konstrukt irgendwie zusammen äh bröselt, aber da kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch mal drauf,
Also im Grunde genommen war FTX eigentlich nichts anderes wie eine Börse sowie auch eine Börse haben kann, um um Aktien zu handeln et cetera auf der ich ähm.
Ja, zunächst mal ganz rein physisch gesehen Bitcoins kaufen und verkaufen konnte oder beziehungsweise Kryptowährung,
und das Ganze dann nochmal ein bisschen gesteigert mit ähm ja Derivaten, also Derivaten ist ja meistens so eine,
Ableitung von einem Ursprungsprodukt, also ähm das Ganze vielleicht noch irgendwie gehebelt, so dass ich dann durch ja mit wenig Geld am Fesentlich mehr verdienen kann oder auch verlieren kann sozusagen,
Ähm FDX war zum Schluss die zweitgröß,
Börse und das ist natürlich einer beeindruckenden Geschwindigkeit. Ich glaube im Mai 2019 hatte St. Die Börse gegründet.
War jetzt im Januar zweitausendzwei, da habe ich die letzten Daten her, hat so ungefähr 23 Millionen Kunden gehabt und bewertet was Unternehmen mit 32 Milliarden.
Das ist erstmal relativ viel aber jetzt müssen wir erstmal nochmal ganz kurz erklären, was sind Derivate und was heißt gehebelt.
Also ein Derivat ist.
Du musst jetzt zum 100. Mal erklären, aber tue einfach so, als als wäre das äh was ganz Neues und Spannendes für dich.
Du hast ja ein Finanzinstrument, sei es ihm jetzt wie ein Bitcoin, wo er wo ein Preis tagtäglich du dort ihm würde. Tag täglich und auch tagtäglich abrufen kannst sozusagen und ein Dirivard ist ja letztendlich eine Ableitung darauf, das heißt also ich versuche mit einem,
Produkt darauf, äh Kursschwankung oder Preis oder Erwartungen oder was auch immer, sozusagen von abzuleiten und konstruiere da ein ein ein,
Ja, ein zweites Produkt on top sozusagen. Und das ist halt so, dass ich dann ähm meistens,
proportional äh daran verdienen oder verlieren kann, also sprich ich habe meistens einen Hebel drin, also du du kaufst nicht irgendwie ein Bitcoin und wenn da ein Euro nach oben geht, dann hast du auch ein Euro gemacht, sondern,
kaufst für einen Euro aber bewegst dafür irgendwie 5 Euro als Beispiel. Das könntest du damit halt abbilden.
Und wie geht das.
Letztendlich funktioniert unser Banksystem oder dein ganzes System da draußen, ja genau, so ist jetzt ja keine keine Besonderheit, was jetzt mit Krypto verbunden ist, sondern wenn du Tim jetzt zu seiner Sparkasse geht in Berlin und da 1000 Euro einzahlt,
Dann kann die Bank ja auch dieses Geld nehmen,
Und darüber hinaus noch wesentlich mehr wegen 1.000 Euro um die an den Linus weiterzuverleihen, was dann ja auch irgendwie ja ein Kreditgeschäft ist. So und dann ähm,
Derivate anbieten auf eine Bank zu sagen, naja ähm weiß ich nicht, dieses oder ich kann dieses Kreditgeschäft dieser Bank zum Beispiel irgendwie absichern. Man kann sagen, okay, wenn das denn irgendwie schief geht, der der Kredit an Linus, dann bin ich nach unten,
also es ist einfach ein Divater, so ein abgeleitetes Produkt auf dem vergebenen Kredit. Nein, ursprünglich kommen so was mal daher, dass du.
Früher mal Bauer gewesen bist und wusstest natürlich nicht wie deine Ernte unter Umständen wirst,
für diese Bauern eingeführt, na ja du kannst jetzt zu einem Preis X deine Ernte schon mal im Herbst verkaufen, somit hatte der Bauer ein gesichertes Einkommen und wusste, was dein Ertrag ist und ähm der andere darauf spekuliert natürlich, dass dann die Ernte vielleicht größer ausfiel, sodass dann durch da mehr hatte.
Daher kommt es ursprünglich ein wenig,
So ein bisschen im gesamten Finanzbank durch ein bisschen ausgeufert. Heute hast du Dirivater auf alles mögliche und bewegst eigentlich Assets und Dinge, die die gar nicht physisch in der Formel da sind. Also sind natürlich wesentlich mehr Kredite im Umlauf, als es überhaupt Geld existiert sozusagen und sicherlich auch teilweise,
mehr Weizen verkauft, weil es wirklich physisch war, jetzt natürlich immer existiert.
Das ist ja jetzt erstmal was äh FTX betrifft jetzt erstmal auch gar nicht der der wichtigste äh Aspekt. Also,
Ganze vielleicht sagen wir erstmal was was jetzt erstmal an sich passiert ist. Also FTX ist eine Firma die gibt's seit zwanzig neunzehn
eine von diesen etwas äh größer gewordenen Kryptoprojekten der letzten Jahre, ist von einem,
Ja, kann man sagen, Nerd äh namens Sam, Bankman Free heißt das so, ja, ne, Free Free oder Free, ne, Free, ne.
Kannst auch Bang Friend.
Oder ja oder Bankman.
Ja
Das trifft's vielleicht am besten. Ähm,
der das halt alles aufgezogen hat und und das ist halt so, wie man das in den letzten Jahren schon öfter beobachtet hat in dieser ganzen Kryptowelt, da tauchen irgendwelche Leute auf und dann wird das irgendwie fett
hochgejubelt und hoch promotet und und dann ist das irgendwie der heiße Scheiß und dann geht das irgendwie rum und auf einmal äh finden da so vollkommen atemberaubende
Wertzuwächse auf dem Papier statt. Das Ganze hat bei ihm glaube ich mit so einer.
Korrigier mich, es ist meine Wahrnehmung, so eine Venture-Capital äh Unternehmung, damit hat das irgendwie angefangen unter dem Namen Alameda und dann hat er dann irgendwann diese online Trainingsbörse FTX gemacht und auch noch ein eigenes Token,
rausgebracht ne, dieses FTT.
Token, das ist ja sozusagen dann auch noch so ein so ein so ein Ding erstmal noch eine eigene Währung machen und dann ist das alles irgendwie aufgeblasen mit Hype und ihm ist halt gelungen, dass äh soweit aufzublasen, dass eben daraus äh ein äh extrem,
hoch und wir wollen jetzt auch wissen
vollkommen überbewertetes äh Unternehmen dabei rausgekommen ist. Was ich dann eben äh in dieser Welt, in dieser unterregulierten Kryptowelt äh in atemberaubender Geschwindigkeit
entwickelt es vielleicht nicht das richtige Wort, sondern vor sich hin Neandert äh hat und,
das ist jetzt alles gecrasht. Es ist äh könnte der größte Crash sein, den die amerikanische Finanzgeschichte bisher so erlebt hat. Bisher war, glaube ich, so Enron so der äh absolute Oberknaller
Punkto, was da alles schiefgegangen ist und äh
der Typ, der sich um Enron gekümmert hat, der hat sich jetzt irgendwie auch FTX angeschaut und meint so, da ging's in Ron irgendwie Pappenstiel gewesen, so, also sowas kompliziertes und so was Krasses hat er noch nie gesehen, also die Katastrophe wäre einfach maximal, können wir auch gleich nochmal drauf eingehen, was da alles schiefgegangen ist. Also das ist sozusagen jetzt die Ausgangssituation, das ist das,
worauf er äh schauen. So und ja, was was ist denn da jetzt übrig geblieben? Von diesem Unternehmer.
Du hast es ja ganz gut zusammengefasst, vielleicht können wir nochmal ein paar Strängen vielleicht so ein bisschen ähm nochmal was mit mit dranpacken, weil's glaube ich dann interessant ist für den Fall. Einerseits, ich glaube, er kommt aus einer Welt,
Also er wird sicherlich intelligent und sehr begabt sein. Da hat man immer IT studiert, glaube ich, zum Schluss ein Abschluss in Physik gemacht,
Eltern sind in einem.
Umfeld, sage ich mal, was ihm natürlich schon mal eben so ein bisschen auf ein paar Stufen höher hebt und natürlich auch es ihm leichter macht, natürlich in dieser ganzen Silicon Valley Welt et cetera, um da natürlich irgendwie an Leute zu kommen und auch besser anzukommen, als wenn wir dreist das wahrscheinlich gemacht hätte.
Ist aufgefallen als,
erstes Mal, ähm dass er bei einem ähm Handelsunternehmen gearbeitet hatte und hatte dort ähm einen wie man sagt jahrelanges Problem gelöst und zwar ähm man sagte, müssen diese Kimshi-Prämie und zwar gibt es Fälle,
dass man ein Bitcoin in kaufen oder kaufen konnte und sie zu einem höheren Preis in Südkorea verkaufen konnte. Er hat es dann damals exzessiv dann auch in Japan betrieben. Also es gab so ein so ein so ein Gefälle sozusagen.
Also das Ausnutzen von unterschiedlichen Kursen an unterschiedlichen Börsen.
Genau, Abbitraschstelle betrieben, angeblich soll er ähm bis zu 25 Millionen Dollar an einem Tag damit verdient haben, wobei viele auch im Internet sagen, ja, ist eher fragwürdig, also das ist jetzt irgendwie schwer nachzuvollziehen, aber zumindest scheint dieses Problem gelöst zu haben, wie man das halt technisch irgendwie abwickelt.
Natürlich erstmal irgendwie bekannt geworden.
Und nicht nur technisch, sondern auch ähm also regulatorisch, ne, weil du äh muss ja irgendwie wenn du in Japan was hat der gemacht, in Japan teurer verkauft oder in Japan teurer eingekauft, weiß ich nicht genau, aber er hat quasi.
Verkauft, ne. Hm, das heißt, er muss dir irgendwie ein Unternehmenskonstrukt haben, was das ermöglicht oder wie, weil eigentlich.
Hätte ich jetzt also halte ich das jetzt nicht für so ein großes Problem in irgendwas in Japan zu verkaufen übers Internet.
Äh wir reden jetzt von schon von Krypto, ne? Also wir reden jetzt von Transaktionen in der Kryptowelt, nicht in der normalen Finanzwelt oder doch.
Wir reden von von Bitcoins reden wir, exakt,
in in Südkorea war's so gewesen, dass ähm große Transaktionen in dem Bereich eigentlich im Land verboten waren. Ich glaube, es hat nur im kleinen Mikrobereich funktioniert und das musstest du einerseits technisch darstellen,
ähm und wahrscheinlich auch musstest du irgendwie über irgendwelche Gesellschaften irgendwie abwickeln, wahrscheinlich hat das auch noch mehr aufgebaut. Ähm
wie, weiß ich nicht, aber zumindest ähm scheint es geklappt zu haben und dann halt damit größere Mengen quasi ähm verdient zu haben.
Könnte allen schon mal eine Erklärung sein, warum am Ende äh in diesem ganzen Konstrukt 163und Firmen bei rausgekommen sind, die alle in irgendeiner Form miteinander verbandelt sind.
Es ist tatsächlich ein wichtiger Baustein, wenn er nämlich so Handel betrieben hat, weil das wird glaube ich gleich nochmal wichtig ähm in dem Punkt zu sagen, wenn man einen Token erstellt, weil der muss ja auch erstmal eine gewisse Poplarität erreichen und da ist glaube ich gut, ein Wissen zu haben, wie man denn so was in mir handelt entsprechend.
Ähm aber in dem Punkt Nummer anzuknüpfen, zweitausendsiebzehn hat er dann ähm gekündigt und hat Alameda Research gegründet. Es war dann eigentlich ein Art Hedgefund.
Und hatte versucht dann dort irgendwie Anlegergelder zu verwalten und ähm hatten auch die Sabitrage betrieben und das Ganze hat man sich über die Zeitlinie gesteigert. Das Ganze hat man auf den Bahamas gemacht. Man hat da, glaube ich, so ein bisschen wie so in einer Kommune gelebt. Es war in so zehn, 20 Leute.
Unterschiedliche Partnerwechsel unter den Leuten dort nun hat sich's irgendwie gut gehen lassen und hat halt diese Plattform betrieben.
Hat er dann daraus abgeleitet halt FDX gegründet um das Ganze natürlich mal so ein bisschen mit anzuheizen und zu unterstützen und hat dann natürlich bei halt irgendwie so seine damalige Freunde entsprechend dort reingesetzt, die das dann entsprechend für ihn äh mitgemanagt hat.
Carolin, Alison hieß die, glaube ich, ja, genau. Genau. Und ähm bei FDX letztendlich glauben wir mal auf diesen Token kommt.
Ist natürlich zunächst mal ganz wichtig gewesen und zwar ähm der Token, diese FDT Token.
Es geht ja darum, dass ich zunächst mal einen Token habe, dann sollte ich möglichst viel für mich irgendwie selber behalten, muss dann zusehen, dass natürlich der Preis von diesem Token schnellstmöglichst äh durch die Decke geht.
Will ich das? Weil wenn der nicht schon mal einen gewissen Wert hat, dann kann ich die natürlich auch als Sicherheit einsetzen. Ich kann hingegen echte Dollar tauschen und so weiter, was natürlich im Spiel hier komplett wichtig ist,
Was hat dieser Token gemacht? Ich habe bei FTX mir ein ein Krypto-Konto eröffnet und wenn ich aber gleichzeitig noch diesen Token gekauft habe, dann habe ich einen äh Preisnachlass bekommen auf meine Tradinggebühren. Das heißt, jeder, der dort einen Account hatte und wollte viel traden,
hat natürlich am Ende des Tages gesagt, boah prima, dann kaufe ich mir noch diesen Token, weil dann kriege ich's natürlich entsprechend billiger. Also habe ich schon mal künstlich irgendwie was heißt künstlich, aber ich habe Nachfrage in diesem Token halt erzeugt.
Also wenn wir sagen Token, dann meint das jetzt in diesem Kontext eher so eine Art lokale Währung innerhalb von FTT. Äh FTX, Entschuldigung.
Nee, also theoretisch ist jede Kryptowährung auch gleichzusetzen, also Kryptowährung oder trockenes Prinzip.
Gleiche Wording, was man aber jetzt eigentlich mittlerweile darunter versteht, ist, dass man ein ein dezentralisierten Finance Token sozusagen hat. Also man deck.
Dockt, sage mal, auf Isse an, führt aber ganz andere Dinge aus. Also ich meine ähm,
Alle Funktionen, die wir in so einem ganz normalen Finanzsystem kennen, also Kreditvergabe, Sparen, Versichern und so weiter,
Das kann man in so einem Token abbilden, setzt aber dann auf der der Plattform oder Bewährung von auf und das ist einfach so ein so ein Token entsprechend, der auf einer anderen Art Wehre und eine Plattform beruht.
Auch mit diesem FDP gemacht, um halt dann, was ich gerade sagte, jetzt nicht sparen, also schon sparen, aber in Form von Tradinggebühren halt.
Man konnte zwischen drei bis teilweise bis zu 60 Prozent der Tradinggebühren bezahlen äh einsparen,
auch noch gemacht hat ist, dass ähm ich glaube er hat 250 Millionen Token damals ausgegeben und hat gesagt na ja,
ein Drittel meiner Tradinggebühren nämlich um den Token zu kaufen, um dann den entsprechend einzustampfen. Das heißt, ich wiege so ein bisschen Inflation entgegen und halt natürlich den Wert entsprechend von so was halt stabil. Das, was man ja auch ursprünglich bei Bitcoin sagt, okay,
Menge es irgendwann mal gedeckelt, es kann nicht mehr geschürft werden, was ja auch so ein bisschen Inflation theoretisch halt irgendwie rausnehmen.
Das natürlich irgendwie wichtig, weil wenn man so einen Druck natürlich begeht, ähm dann ähm,
Wenn ich dann mal erstmal den Token irgendwie habe und ihn bekannt gemacht habe, dann kann ich natürlich diesen äh Token nehmen,
zum Beispiel irgendwelchen Pensionsfonds anbieten und sagen, guck mal, hier noch diesen Token, ähm gebt mir doch ein bisschen Geld dafür und somit kannst du dich dann Eigenkapital in einer Firma irgendwie massiv erhöhen,
Eigenkapital und das Geld, was du liegen hast, kannst du dich dann wieder neben Kredite irgendwie zu nehmen. Ähm das einfach eigentlich wie so eine Art Schwungrad,
wertvolle der Token wird, desto wertvoller wird dein Unternehmen. Du kannst es für Dollar einsammeln. Du kannst zu irgendwelchen Pension Fund gehen, gab's ja in Kanada, die ihm Geld gegeben haben. Du hast ihm Geld gegeben haben und so weiter,
und somit äh läuft es immer weiter,
zum Schluss dann hat ja auch gemacht Namensrechte von Stadienkaufs, Politiker, glaube Joe Biden glaube ich 50 Millionen von ihm bekommen,
solange dieses Schwungrad irgendwie lief, ne token immer populärer wurde, hattest du genug Geld und Sicherheiten, um natürlich alles am Laufen zu halten. Und somit hast du,
kürze ein relativ großes Unternehmen entsprechend aufgepumpt.
Investoren gab's äh eine eine Menge. Du hast ja schon ein paar äh genannt. Also es gab eine ganze Menge, die dann sozusagen äh in sein Projekt auch äh
ja an seinem Projekt geglaubt haben und in sein Projekt dann auch eine ganze Menge Geld reingesteckt haben. Ich habe auch Softbank war da äh mit dabei und die haben alle so irgendwie bis zu einer
Milliarde Dollar dann glaube ich reingeworfen in der Größenordnung zumindest.
Ähm und dieser ich meine, das ist natürlich auch immer sehr interessant, ne, wenn solche Pensions äh fands, die halt ja eigentlich,
würde ich jetzt zumindest mal erwarten eher konservativ spielen sollten, damit sie eben die Renten nicht äh in Gefahr bringen, weil dafür ist es ja da, ne verwalten das Geld
der äh Rentenbeitragszahler, damit eben das Geld gemehrt wird, um daraus eben dann
Renten zu zahlen, ne und wenn ihr das dann halt in solche waghalsigen Kryptoprojekte äh stecken und das Ganze explodiert, dann äh stehen die ja natürlich auch schön doof da.
Ich hoffe, dass die breit gestreut haben, dass nur eine kleine Position war, aber ähm ja irgendwo wird's hier natürlich schon noch wehtun.
Durch die Frage stellen kann, auch investiert gewesen, dass ja auch so ein Kuriosum.
Die eigentlich als eine der bekanntesten Venture Capital Funds in den USA gelten.
Die sich auf die Fahne schreiben, na ja, wir gucken uns sozusagen jede Schraube an und du hast es ja gerade selber erwähnt, dass es hier ein Konstrukt war von mehreren äh hunderten äh von Tochterfirmen. Also wenn ich so ein Konstrukt sehe, ich sehen würde, würde ich irgendwie meine äh Beine in die Hand nehmen und weglaufen. Also ich glaube.
Die Frage ist halt, wie weit haben die da wirklich reingeguckt? Ich möchte da niemand was unterstellen, aber es klingt für mich schon sehr kurios.
Kurios geht's nämlich dann weiter ähm Südkorea hat's ähm äh ihm Geld gegeben, 200 Millionen, aber gleichzeitig hat er aber auch 200 Millionen in dem Sequoria Fund investiert.
Man hat sich gegenseitig eigentlich so ein bisschen hochgepumpt sozusagen. Gib du mir 2hundert Millionen. Ich meine, es ist nicht üblich in der Avengers-Szene. Äh ist üblich in der Avengers-Szene, aber das ist so schnell passiert und dann äh Eddie, glaube ich, mehr in dem Pfand sogar eingezahlt als er von denen bekommen hat.
Mhm. Was soll das.
Ich gehe in den Supermarkt, kaufe eine Tüte Milch und vorher gehe ich arbeiten, damit ich das Geld habe. So Hafermilch und die kaufen sich gegenseitig also warum.
Vorher investiert ähm tun sie's ja auf einer gewissen Bewertung, hat natürlich eine gewisse Ausstrahlkraft,
nächste sagt oh, wenn die dabei sind, die haben genau hingeguckt, na ja dann steigen wir auch ein, wahrscheinlich zu einer höheren Bewertung,
heißt deine eigene Firma ist mehr wert und gleichzeitig hast du aber noch dein eigenes privates Geld in dem Pfand geparkt, der dich auch im Wert steig war und durch einen Asset wertvoller geworden ist. Das heißt, letztendlich haben sie,
gegenseitig die Werte von einem Fonds als aber auch von der Company letztendlich nach oben geschrau.
Und wenn er dann der äh SBF sozusagen gleich die dieselbe Menge wieder zurückinvestiert hat, dann hat sie's äh unterm Strich gar nichts gekostet. Aber darüber berichtet dann keiner.
Die Frage ist natürlich, woher das Geld genau kam aus dem FDX-Bereich sicherlich nicht.
Ist ja noch die große Frage aus anderen Investitionen, wo ist von was irgendwie was hingeflossen kann, die aus dem Hedgefond gekommen sein. Da schließt sich ja so ein bisschen der Kreis.
Die Hedgefonds, FTX, obwohl sich's ja eigentlich gar nicht sollten, haben wir dann trotzdem irgendwie zusammengearbeitet. Also im Headshow hat man da ganz langsam angefangen, hat auch Abiture betrieben,
Und irgendwann ging das alles viel zu langsam auch dieses Rad irgendwie schneller gedreht,
und ähm hat dann tatsächlich auch FDX Kundendaten genommen, die ausgewertet, um zu wissen, okay, die die breite Masse auf meiner Tradingplattform macht jetzt gerade X und hat natürlich dann die Information genommen, um selbst daraus Profil zu schlagen, um sich dann vielleicht die Gegenseite einzunehmen oder was auch immer halt,
hat sich schon gegenseitig da irgendwie befruchtet.
Ja, also es ist auf jeden Fall eine eine sehr undurchsichtige äh Geschichte. Ähm ich denke in dieser ganzen Firmenkonstruktion am Ende lief es im Prinzip so auf so vier wesentliche Teile äh hinaus, wenn ich das jetzt richtig erinnere. Also es gab
auf der einen Seite dieses Alarmeda, was es halt ganz am Anfang gab, diese äh Hedgefront ähm,
Geschichte. Also vielleicht kannst du nochmal kurz sagen, was ein Hedgefront so normalerweise tut.
Also sagen wir Hedgefond im Vergleich jetzt zu mir. Bei mir ist es einmal die Juice-Fan, sagt man dazu. Es ist einfach unter normalen Statuten geregelt beim Hedgefahren sind es,
sehr konzentrierte Wetten, die man äh da fährt und die unterliegen auch einer noch sorgfältigeren ähm,
A Überprüfung und B kann nicht jeder also dort investieren. Also wenn ihr dort investieren wolltet, könnt ihr den zumindest nicht direkt bei der Sparkasse kaufen. Mhm.
Weil nicht auch dieses Produkt ähm deutlich höhere Risiken birgt und in diesem Fall kann natürlich alles Mögliche passieren. Kannst du wirklich nur irgendwie eine Aktie besitzen. Du kannst aber auch irgendwie wesentlich viele Wetten ähm fahren, die natürlich hoch risikoreich sind. Und darum ist natürlich so ein Vehikel selber natürlich,
geschützt und eben nicht für die breite Anlegermasse entsprechend geeignet.
So, das heißt, das hat er mit Krypto äh gemacht. Dann hat er halt dieses äh diese FTX-Trainingbörse äh gestartet, aber er hat ja auch noch,
noch ein noch einen eigenen ähm Bereich auch noch gehabt, wo er dann wiederum in andere,
Kryptoprojekte investiert hat. Das war ja auch noch mit im Spiel.
Sogar gerettet haben, ne? Also ich habe ja schon vorher einige die Pleite gegangen sind. Er wurde ja als großer Retter gefeiert, dass er halt mit dem Geld sozusagen auch noch diese gerettet hat.
Dieser Punkt wo er angefangen hat und das ist natürlich das große Manko, weil er eigentlich gegen seine eigenen Turms äh äh verstoßen hat, dass halt.
Eine eine Bilanz funktioniert ja so, dass du eine Aktivseite und eine Passivseite hast, also auf der Aktivseite hast du dein dein Umlaufvermögen, also deine Kaffeemaschine bei seiner Stelle und sein das Anlagevermögen, das ist das Geld, was eben die Kunden gegeben haben,
auf der Passivseite hast du Verbindlichkeiten, nämlich dass der Kunde natürlich jederseits Zeit sein sein Geld wiederbekommen möchte. Das heißt, wenn du wenn er eine Milliarde von den Kunden bekommen hat, dann wollen die irgendwann mal vielleicht wieder dran, also musst du jederzeit in der Lage sein, diese eine auch wieder auszuzahlen halt,
Eigenkapital, das ist natürlich das, was dann eher bei der Gründung mit reingegeben hat plus das, was so ein Venture Capital Fund vielleicht mit ihm wieder reinpackt und wenn er Gewinne macht, die sich Ende des Jahres da irgendwie aufaddieren.
Aber von diesen die Bank, die ist die die Bilanz war 16 Milliarden groß, hat aber halt zehn Milliarden davon genommen und die hat die aber dann in den Hedgefand transferiert, um mit den Gelder eben zu spekulieren und das ist ihm natürlich dann immer um die Ohren geflogen.
Aber machen das also das also äh das wiederum ist doch.
Halbwegs normal oder? Also das sind Bankrun zu jedem Zeitpunkt eine Gefahr ist,
mir relativ klar. Also wenn im Finanzsystem alle gleichzeitig sagen wohl sagen, sie würden gerne sehen, dann funktioniert das nicht, ne? Ähm.
Was gibt's da für was gibt's da für Regeln? Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel jemand sagt, na ja gut, hier sechzehn äh,
Millionen oder Milliarden oder Token oder was auch immer, ist eigentlich egal.
Äh zehn davon nehme ich jetzt mal hier als Spielgeld raus. Klar, dann trägt er die ins Risiko, aber solange das gut geht, quengelt ja keiner, ne? Solange das gut geht, kommt und sagt, komm hier äh,
Mach mal nochmal den Trick. Und wenn das dann.
Usammenbricht, dann sind alle am quengeln. Aber das passiert ja irgendwie so,
wirklich sehr äh sehr regelmäßig alle.
Alle paar Jahre und es ist jetzt, wie du ja auch schon sagtest, nicht irgendwie was völlig Neues oder dass sowas passiert.
Nee, das ist nicht wirklich neu
ich meine im Grunde genommen ist es ja so, als ob du zu deinem Sparkassenberater gehst, ihm tausend Euro gibst und er sagt, ah prima, ich nehme jetzt mal diese 1tausend Euro und äh investiere es in, was hast du da so, Hafermilch äh oder Beyond Meat oder sowas investierst du's in Aktien am besten noch gehebelt.
Habe ich gemacht. Kann ich nicht empfehlen.
Okay.
Auch nicht.
Problem wenn der Bankberater das mit den 1000 Euro gemacht hätte gehebelt dann wäre natürlich das Geld irgendwie futsch und dann ist ja die Frage was passiert halt irgendwie dann. Das heißt bei einer Bank gibt's natürlich
die Bank könnte das und wird sie auch tun, aber es geht natürlich um Regulaier und da ist es der Punkt, was du durch so einen ähm im wie im Kryptobereich nicht haben
dass ich durch gewisses Eigenkapital hinterlegen muss und das Eigenkapital ist dann auch noch Risiko gewichtet,
Also wenn ich als Bank nur Kredite vergeben würde und das nur an boah weiß ich nicht Zahnärztin, dann ist die Auswahl wahrscheinlichkeit von diesen Krediten wahrscheinlich relativ gering. Das heißt,
muss relativ wenig Eigenkapital, also eigenes Geld, was auf meiner Bank und meinem Buch liegt, wenig davon hinterlegen, kann aber trotzdem relativ viel Kredite vergeben.
Feststellen, okay ist doof, verdiene ich nicht so viel mit,
Fange ich jetzt aber an auf Oatlige Hebel zu äh zu hantieren, dann ist natürlich das Risiko deutlich höher, also muss ich auch mehr Eigenkapital hinterlegen. Und das alles musste er ja nicht, weil's eben nicht irgendeine Regiktorik äh unterliegt.
Weil einfach im Krypto-Land ist halt einfach Wildwest und äh da gibt's,
Vorschriften, ne? Da kann man machen, was man will und ja und am Ende äh stehen wir jetzt,
und man findet quasi so dieses gesamte
Firmengebilde vor, was deutlich weniger Geld zu haben scheint als ja alle Verbindlichkeit,
von denen man bisher weiß, äh so darstellen. Ne, es gibt irgendwie über eine Milliarde äh über eine Million Schuldner, äh die jetzt hier stehen und sagen, ja was was ist denn jetzt hier mit meiner Kohle? Aber es sieht halt nicht so aus
als ob dieses Geld in irgendeiner Form da ist, abgesichert ist durch durch äh irgendetwas und das halt auch Largescale. Also das ist hier wirklich,
so viel Kohle nicht da ist, dass äh ja sich alle fragen, was denn jetzt überhaupt los und das Ganze ist halt jetzt.
Also es war mal da, es hat nur.
Ja ja also es ist es war mal da, aber äh jetzt beginnen also wir stehen ja auch erst
ganz am Anfang der Untersuchung, die Insolvenz ist halt jetzt angemeldet worden, also es ist ja diese Chapter äh eleven Geschichte in USA, ne, also der,
nach dem Motto ja Firma ist vermutlich zahlungsunfähig. Man stellt diesen Antrag, gibt's ja bei uns auch, sodass eben erstmal gar nichts bezahlt werden darf und dann kommt der Insolvenzverwalter, schaut sich das mal genau an, was denn da ist und dann wird das halt dann wird halt geguckt, was man damit
damit machen kann mit so einem äh,
ne? Also ob das jetzt sozusagen was wert ist, dann werden die Teile verkauft. Daraus wird äh Geld verdient, ne aber in so einem Kryptoladen gibt's halt
eigentlich gar keine Werte, werden wir vielleicht nachher auch noch mal drüber äh reden so. Dann gibt's natürlich die reinen Krypto-Coints,
Die waren wohl auch nur so begrenzt auffindbar. Also es gab zwar welche, aber halt dann auch nur so für 700 Millionen Euro oder Dollar äh und vor allem, du hast doch viel geiler ist, man wusste überhaupt nicht,
Wem jetzt eigentlich was gehört? Also es gab irgendwie keine ordentliche kein ordentliches Bookheeping da drüber.
Welche.
Den anderen Kriminellen gelernt, ja? Kann ich erst anfangen.
Ich möchte noch ich möchte noch kurz, weil wir jetzt schon so bei dem Untergang sind, ne? Ich meine, der Typ war offenbar weltbekannt als irgendwie Jesus,
ne. Dick es gibt irgendwelche Podien, wo der mit Tony Blair und ähm Bill Clinton sitzt. So,
und er sitzt da irgendwie im im in einer in einer in einer kurzen Hose mit einem T-Shirt
und ist dann mitm Toyota-Corolla irgendwie neunziger Jahre Baujahr selber hingefahren, ne? Also der hat äh,
mit seinem Effective Alltroism hat er tatsächlich ja auch für viele Leute ähm.
Ja durchaus ein ein Vorbild und auch eine Inspiration der der Umverteilung. So ähm schon,
Also der hat das, der hat das weit getrieben, weil was wir jetzt so sagen, gehört sich halt alles an, als wäre das ein absoluter Scammer, ja, ist er ja auch, aber der hat's der ist der wurde erst mal
international respektiert als Mensch, der es versteht, aus Scheiße Geld zu machen und das ist so die höchste Anerkennung, die du kriegen kannst.
In dem Zusammenhang muss man auch nochmal über Toni Player und Bill Clinton reden an der Stelle sich da auch irgendwie.
Ich sage ja nur höchste Anerkennung, die du kriegen kannst.
Ich unterstelle noch nicht mal, glaube ich, kriminelle Absicht. Ich glaube, dass es,
irgendwann mal so groß geworden ist und einem so über den Kopf gewachsen ist, dass er A die Kontrolle verloren hat und dann warst du da so sehr im Strudel drin, dass du dann wahrscheinlich kriminell geworden bist. Ich glaube nicht, dass du das von Tag 1 angegründet hast, um kriminelle Dinge zu tun. Das das glaube ich nicht
Ich meine es gibt auch diese Geschichten, dass ähm er einen Schreibtisch hatte und daneben einen Schreibtisch mit so einem so einer Vorrichtung, worauf man aufm Tisch schlafen kann. Wenn man die Leute in Meetingräume geführt und da war eine Glasscheibe und durch die Glasscheibe konnte man sein sein äh,
Schreibtisch sehen,
geschlafen, hat sich dann absichtlich wecken lassen und dann wurde alles so vorgetäuscht, um das sah so ein bisschen den coolen Guy spielt und dann dieses Meeting kam, indem er da nämlich einen Computerspiele noch nebenbei gespielt hat, während er oben Milliarden gefeilscht hat.
Schon so sich so als Person natürlich da auch so aufgebaut, klar, gehört auch mit zum Spiel.
Interessant übrigens ist, wo wir grad kurz noch mit Derivate gesprochen haben. Das hatte ich heute noch mal von von jemandem gehört. Wenn ich gehebelt etwas kaufe, das heißt, ich ähm bezahle eins, aber kann fünf bewegen, dann ähm.
Trotzdem noch vielleicht nochmal eins und Top irgendwie als Sicherheit hinterlegen. Das ist so eine Art so eine Margenpuffer und wenn diese Margen aufgebraucht ist, dann ruft mich jemand an, wenn sie nicht gegen mich läuft. Die wird schon sagt, ah hier deine Sicherheit, die du hinterlegt hast. Sie reicht nicht mehr aus, bitte schieß noch mal nach.
Anderen Kryptowährungen ist es so, da Kryptobörsen ist es so wie bei Kraken et cetera. Sobald du nur einen Center drüber bist, wird diese Position glattgestellt.
War es aber so, dass so eine Art Graubereich gab
kamst, deine Marge reicht nicht mehr aus und dann fiel die Position weiter. Man hat dich aber gewähren lassen. Also die haben das schon bis aufs Maximum schon ausgereizt, um dass du da damit zocken konntest. Also es gab keine harte Risikokontrolle. In dem Sinne, sondern sagt,
Im Minus, dein Geld reicht nicht mehr aus. Tschüss, das haben sie halt eben nicht gemacht.
Also man ist auf jeden Fall sehr offensichtlich, dass äh,
vermutlich, wie so viele von diesen Whiskys dort äh in den Kryptobereich schon verstanden haben, wie dieser ganze Kryptomarkt funktioniert im Sinne von, also wie es technisch an sich funktioniert, was was es
tatsächlich ist, ja und äh sich dann aber wir alle diesen Träumen äh hingeben, was es dann vielleicht auch sein könnte oder was es meint zu sein, ja, nämlich irgendwie richtiges Geld
und äh dann anfangen in diesem Regulationsfreien Bereich quasi alles nochmal.
Äh ja, alle Fehler nochmal zu begehen und alle, alle kriminellen Konstruktionen, die so in dem in der echten Finanzwelt in 100 Jahren vorher schon mal probiert wurden, die dann eben auch nochmal in so ein Business-Kostüm zu gießen, weil es gibt ja
keine Grenzen und dabei aber auch vollständig äh losgelöst von irgendeinem Businesswissen, weil wenn man sich jetzt eben
anschaut, was berichtet wird, dass also haben Sie ja schon gesagt, also es gibt kein richtiges äh Bookhaining, also so richtig überhaupt gar keine Buchhaltung. Die ganzen Entscheidungen, die dort gefällt wurden, wurden in so Chats gefällt
wo so drei Leute drin waren, die dann irgendwie mit Emojis geantwortet haben, so, ne, also nach dem Motto, hier soll irgendwo Geld irgendwo hin und dann waren das aber so Kanäle, die dann die Nachrichten nach einer bestimmten Zeit auch wieder automatisch gelöscht haben. Also es gibt halt überhaupt
keinerlei Track Record, was überhaupt jemals wann zu welchem Zeitpunkt für irgendwelche Entscheidungen gefällt hat, wohin Geld
gehen soll. Äh die Kundenkonten sind nicht richtig äh aufgeführt und auch wahrscheinlich diese gesamte äh Firmenkonstellation ist wahrscheinlich auch ein einziges Towabo. Ich meine, da muss man ja schon wirklich sehr krass
äh die Realität ignorieren, wenn man nahezu gegen alle Vorgaben verstößt, die
man jetzt aufgelegt bekommt als amerikanisches Unternehmen. Ich meine, dass viele Freiheiten haben, aber halt beileibe nicht so viele, wie sie sich da rausgenommen haben.
Ja noch dazu, dass sich diese ganzen Unternehmen auch noch untereinander und vor allem,
auch noch eine ganze Menge Darlehen gegeben haben. Also ich glaube irgendwie so.
Ein, zwei Milliarden sind allein irgendwie diesen diesen Gesellschaftern, vor allem ihm äh gegeben worden intern und es gibt auch darüber keine Aufzeichnung warum und,
wieso und so weiter, es ist einfach absurd, was da abgeht.
Meine Höhepunkt und letztendlich scheitert ja alles an diesem Token. Ich meine, diese Darlehen wohnen ja auch auf dem Wert dieses Token halt irgendwie gegeben unter anderem.
Was wichtig in dieser Geschichte ist, dass es in eine Plattform gibt, die noch größer ist als die FDX und jetzt immer noch die Größte ist, das ist ähm Binance in in China.
Der Gründe dort, Ziseth war einer der ersten Investoren auch bei FDX gewesen.
Mal wurde es aber ihm zu groß diese Investition. Hat er gesagt, naja okay, ich möchte hier raus. Ähm bitte kauft mich doch raus und statt das aber hard Cash genommen hat, wurde er auch in diesem Token bezahlt,
Genau das ist natürlich jetzt FDX zum zum Verhängnis geworden weil,
Also wie du wie ihr grad schon gesagt hattet, äh Sam Bam Freedman waren durch schon auch auf der Schiene unterwegs. Na ja, dieses ganze Business hier muss auch reguliert werden.
Das hat man natürlich nicht so gerne gesehen, insbesondere so lautet es wohl, dass natürlich jetzt gesagt wurde, na ja schaut mal, wir sind Amerikaner, wir müssen zusammenhalten und er hat ja auch beiden relativ viel gespendet, dieses 50 Millionen,
wahrscheinlich drauf hinausgelaufen, dass irgendwie die Amerikaner weitermachen dürfen und man die Chinesen so ein bisschen aus diesem Markt halt rausnimmt.
Durch deine Chinese eben nicht geschmeckt, insbesondere dem Gründer von halt nicht,
und ähm es kam dann schon ein bisschen so Gerüchte auf, dass dieser Hedgefand eben ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten war und daraufhin hat dann gesagt, so, weißt du was, ähm ich habe jetzt keine Lust mehr auf dich. Ähm er hat getwittert, dass hier alles cam ist bei dir,
angefangen diesen Token halt am Markt zu verkaufen. Und damit war natürlich äh Ende im Gelände. Ähm und zumal ging's ihm offensichtlich auch wirklich nicht um Geld.
Die Dame aus dem Hedge fand ihm nochmal glaube 22 Dollar pro Token geboten hat und der Token aber aktuell bei 19 stand. Das heißt also die Dame hätte mehr bezahlt als äh der Marktpreis gerade her gab, wenn's ihm wirklich um Kohle gegangen wäre, hätte er durch das Geld genommen,
er hat gesagt, nö, ich verkaufe jetzt hier alles,
dieser Ton war nicht gerade sehr, sehr liquid, da ist nicht sehr viel umgegangen. Also ihr wisst, was passiert, wenn ich,
verkaufen will, denn der Markt, der nicht liquid ist, das Ganze fällt natürlich wie ein Stein.
Damit war durch alles kaputt, also seine Sicherheiten, die er hinterlegt hatte, der Token war nichts mehr wert. Der Hedgefand,
Eigenkapital bestand auch nur aus diesem Togen. Auch der Headshow war nichts mehr wert gewesen und somit waren natürlich all deine Businesses am am Ende gewesen.
Inwiefern denkst du denn, wird das jetzt äh so ein Domino äh Effekt haben? Oder denkst du das überhaupt.
Also einmal muss man ja sagen, dieser dieser.
Also man kann argumentieren, dass er sagt, ich mag diese Regulierung nicht, die er da irgendwie angestoßen hat. Kann ich nachvollziehen. Auf der anderen Seite hat er sich aber auch im Bärendienst selbst irgendwie erwiesen, weil natürlich jetzt dieses ganze Umfeld, diese ganze Thematik rund um Krypto natürlich jetzt absolut ins Negative gezogen wurde.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr auch dadurch Kunden verliert und dadurch grundsätzlich im gesamten System natürlich jetzt irgendwie Abbuchungen gesehen, also viele Kunden haben jetzt natürlich ihre Bitcoins entsprechend auf diesen Onlinebörsen irgendwie abgehoben,
übrigens das war schon immer eine gute Idee äh seine Kryptos nicht auf irgendwelche Onlinebörsen liegen zu lassen, sondern die möglichst vielleicht in so einem Cold Storage so ein so ein sich Nano so einen Letscher irgendwie zu laden et cetera aber ähm das das nur am Rande irgendwie erwähnt,
schon jetzt ihm natürlich keinen guten Dienst damit erwiesen.
Bleibt natürlich die Nummer eins, hat irgendwie eins seinen ärgsten Verfolger irgendwie jetzt irgendwie abgeschüttelt, aber dafür sind durch jetzt das Thema Bitcoin erst mal äh ganz schön verbrannt und ist die Frage, wann sich das natürlich irgendwie wieder erholt.
Erwähnen muss ähm äh jetzt hat China die größte Krypto-Plattform äh das größte Social Network mit TikTok und irgendwie den größten E-Commerce Anbieter mit mit Alibaba, also fast zumindest,
Also soviel mal zur China-Enkopplung, also ist irgendwie eine China-Zentralisierung. Ob die Amerikaner so was lustig finden, wahrscheinlich auch eher nicht.
Ich finde das interessant, gerade äh jetzt mit Binance, weil ja eigentlich Kryptomining in China ja eigentlich äh verboten worden ist oder habe ich da irgendwas falsch verstanden.
Äh genau, ist verboten worden.
Aber sie haben kein Problem damit, wenn's da irgendwie eine Kryptobörse macht.
Verdient offensichtlich nicht.
Mhm. Okay. Muss man auch nicht verstehen, ne? Ähm,
ja also um nochmal meine Frage nochmal
kurz nochmal nachzustellen. Also gehst du davon aus, dass das jetzt sozusagen auch noch weitere Opfer ähm
nach sich ziehen wird oder kann es auch sein, dass das jetzt,
so einen singulärer Take-Out ist und ähm.
Der Kryptomarkt erstmal weiter äh halbwegs stabil vor sich hin eiert.
Nee, ich glaube schon, dass noch Leute in in Mitleidenschaft zieht. Ich gebe dir noch einige Player, die auch, ich sage mal, diesen Token mit im Importfolio hatten, die jetzt auch grade noch mal schauen, okay, wie viel Geld haben wir jetzt irgendwie wirklich, wie viel es vernichtet wollen? Ich glaube schon, dass noch mal ein, zwei mit sich ziehen wird.
Kraken ist ja auch eine Plattform in USA, die jetzt glaube ich die Nummer drei geworden sind, die relativ strikt und liquide sind,
glaube ich jetzt nur der einzige Strohalm, die jetzt überlegen, na ja vielleicht können wir irgendwie FX doch noch mal irgendwie kaufen und irgendwie was rausschlagen,
hat das übrigens auch überlegt. Das hat den Kurs Verfall ja noch ein bisschen gestoppt. Die haben gesagt, na ja okay, wir gucken uns das Ganze mal an. Aber zum Schluss gesagt, okay, wir lassen doch besser die Finger davon und kaufen irgendwie hier nichts,
Ich kann mir es nicht vorstellen, dass Kraken jetzt irgendwie dann doch noch was findet, vor allem wenn nichts irgendwie dokumentiert ist, auf welcher Basis man dann da irgendwas kauft.
Ich glaube es wird noch seine weiteren Kreise ziehen euch mal das ist natürlich jetzt einfach nur ein Problem was natürlich die Branche an sich betrifft. Deshalb erstmal per se,
egal was du jetzt von Bitcoin und Kryptowährung hält oder nicht natürlich nichts mit der Kryptowährung an sich zu tun. Also ich meine Bitcoin liefert noch genau das, was die Leute daran gut finden oder was die Leute daran schlecht finden. Aber ist natürlich jetzt einfach eine.
Ein Markt oder ein ein ein Stempel aufgeklebt worden, der natürlich erstmal mit der Sache an sich nichts zu tun hat. Das ist wie so ein Skandal, das ist natürlich mies, aber hat natürlich nichts grundsätzlich mit meinem Aktienmarkt zu tun.
Ja mh Linus hast du noch eine Frage zu FTX jetzt im Speziellen.
Äh eher jetzt kaufen oder noch ein bisschen.
Sonst sonst würde ich mal ein bisschen ähm allgemeiner äh werden und das ist natürlich ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen schwierig äh hier vorhersagen äh zu machen, blicken wir vielleicht mal so ein bisschen mehr zurück, Daniel du bist ja jetzt sagen wir mal,
sehr zu Hause im, ich sage mal, so in der normalen Geldwelt. Mir fällt jetzt gerade kein besserer Begriff äh dafür ein, ne.
Ähm dieses äh Kryptogeld Phänomen.
Geht ja jetzt schon eine Weile um. Wir haben das ja hier auch schon mehrfach kritisch,
betrachtet und ist auch glaube ich kein Geheimnis, dass wir das auch weiterhin alles sehr äh kritisch sehen.
Wie äh hast du denn das jetzt,
wahrgenommen, wie verhält sich diese Welt zur restlichen Finanzwelt? Ich meine, es gibt ja auch einige klassische Player, hat man ja jetzt auch gerade mit diesem mit diesem Beispiel, die ja auch
da äh Dollar zeichnen in den Augen haben und dort
dort mitspielen, teilweise ist es ja auch schon so insbesondere in die US äh Republikanische Politecke reingeschwappt, dass das dort auch eine gewisse politische Rolle zu spielen scheint,
Ähm wie nimmst du das wahr? Wie sich das äh entwickelt hat und welche Bedeutung hat es derzeit? Also,
Würde jetzt, so sagen wir mal, alles kollabieren, wäre der Rest der Wirtschaft davon schon nennenswert betroffen oder ist es äh noch komplett separat.
Ich glaube, der grundsätzlich der Kryptomarkt ist noch zu klein, als dass man das irgendwie als als äh großes Risiko für die Finanzfeld irgendwie benennen würde. Das haben jetzt ja auch ganz viele irgendwie gesagt in dem Bereich, dass man das nicht in dieser Stufe diesem dem Risiko unterliegt,
Auswirkungen, aber nicht so, dass der gesamte Finanzmarkt darunter kollabieren könnte. Ist jetzt nicht so wie 2tausendacht,
wo wir die Leberpleite hatten wollen natürlich das ganze System da irgendwie für gewisse Zeit irgendwie still stand.
Glaube Krypto grundsätzlich und mit Krypto meine ich jetzt zunächst erstmal, wenn wir auf der normalen Basis bleiben, wie Bitcoin findet die schon eine Finanzwelt immer mehr Anklang. Ähm.
Entweder dass man ihm die Fonds drauf einrichtet, ETFs et cetera, ähm die den das abbilden. Ähm.
Es war lange Zeit so gedacht, dass man das einstufte in Richtung ähm Gold, dass man sagt, na ja, es ist ein bisschen negativ korreliert, also sprich wenn Aktienmärkte fallen, dann bleibt der Wert dort stabil, das was mir auch irgendwie,
Gold eben entsprechend nachsagt, insbesondere auch dann, wenn die Inflation hoch ist,
Wundern und jetzt haben wir diese Phase wir haben eine hohe Inflation und die Aktienmärkte fallen. Ja und wenn wir jetzt auf den Bitcoin-Kurs äh schauen, dann hat das jetzt nicht wirklich zur Absicherung beigetragen, sondern halt irgendwie auch entsprechend seine 50 Prozent verloren, wie vielleicht irgendwie äh eine krasse Tech-Aktie halt,
tatsächlich bisher eben nicht das geliefert, was dem lange nachgesagt wurde und was versprochen wurde.
Ob das jetzt im Ganzen irgendwie einen Abbruch tut, dass jetzt irgendwie ähm Leute doch weniger im Bitcoin oder in in Krypto investieren, das bezweifle. Ich glaube, wenn ich mit Rigatorik im Hintergrund anschaue, dann nimmt das eher weiter zu.
Family Office nehme, also äh Vermögensverwalter für für reiche Familien et cetera ist das schon da ein ein Baustein in der Lokation. Also ich glaube, das das wird nicht weggehen.
Ich meine, wir haben vor sich 1.0000 verschiedene Kryptowährungen, dass da durch,
viel Mist dabei ist und auch eine Menge von nicht überleben wird. Ich glaube, das ist auch klar, weil vieles auch tatsächlich einfach absolut keinen Sinn ergibt.
Was ich mir vorstellen kann, was halt über bleibt, ist hier mal gerade über dieses Dezentralisierte gesprochen, dass das natürlich schon Anwendung finden kann, aber durch ein solchen System,
relativ viel Ineffizienzen haben einerseits und auf der anderen Seite auch durch Leute an ganz vielen Stellen und Punkten die Hand aufhalten und ziemlich viel Geld verlangen.
Ich glaube, das macht unserem Finanzsystem halt keinen Sinn und lässt sich halt darüber halt schon abbilden.
Aber da stehen wir glaube ich noch eher am Anfang als dass es natürlich morgen einen Schalter umlegt und sagen, so jetzt haben wir die perfekte Struktur halt.
Also wie ich rede von so was wie ähm wenn ich jetzt eine Aktie mal einen Fond kaufe, dann ist ja dahinter eine Buchhaltung, was alles das, was Sam bei nicht hatte. Ähm eine gewisse eine Buchhaltung, die sagt, okay, jetzt wurde diese Aktie gekauft zu dem Kurs und ja Wert dieses Fonds ist jetzt irgendwie X,
Leider äh vergeht ist es ein Tag Verzug bis sowas entsprechend verbucht ist und auch sichtbar ist,
natürlich sowas entsprechend mit äh ähm mit seiner Blockchain entsprechend abbilden, dann geht sowas natürlich halt in Sekunden oder nicht Sekunden, aber zumindest in ein paar Minuten letztendlich.
Wollen natürlich auch noch Geld haben, das Geld kannst du aus dem System rausnehmen und so weiter. Von sowas spreche ich halt. Und ich glaube, dass das schon eine Zukunft haben kann, aber davon sind wir natürlich nur weiter entfer.
Aber es ändert ja alles nichts an der Tatsache, ich würde es meistens eine Tatsache bezeichnen, dass er das die gesamte Krypto Geldwelt.
Ja letztlich keinen anderen Wert darstellt als sie selbst.
Es hat keinen inneren Wert.
Es hat keinen keinen inneren Wert, der in irgendeiner Form greifbar wäre, äh aus dem man, von dem man was hätte, ja, außer, dass es halt irgendwie,
permanent betrieben werden muss und man ja auch noch die ganze Zeit Geld reinstecken muss, damit es überhaupt erstmal Geld bleibt,
Ne, also Computer müssen betrieben werden et cetera, der Aufwand ist relativ groß. Hat es äh,
geschafft zumindest sich diesen Proof of Work äh vom Hals zu erhalten jetzt indem sie umgestiegen sind auf das andere System womit der Stromverbrauch vielleicht ähm deutlich sinken dürfte in Zukunft,
Bitcoin nach wie vor den Großteil davon ausmacht ähm noch mit unklaren Aussichten, inwiefern das dann auch äh technisch hält,
aber diese ganze Geschichte.
Stellt er nichts dar. So und da ist keine wirtschaftliche Aktivität damit verbunden. Also wie bewertest du das,
selbst und und und warum denkst du, lassen sich trotzdem so viele darauf ein.
Also mit dem inneren Wert würde ich dir nur zustimmen, was jetzt als Beispiel irgendwie Bitcoin angeht. Das Gleiche wünsche ich auch für Gold äh,
also Gold hat ja auch kein keinen äh inneren Wert, sondern das, was es halt ausmacht und das trifft auf Bitcoin auch zu, dass es limitiert ist.
Wieso hat Gold keinen inneren Wert.
Wert meine ich, wenn ich jetzt ähm eine Aktie kaufe wie wo eine BMW,
hat es ja auch einen inneren Wert in Form von, dass ich irgendwelche Produktionsanlagen et cetera verkaufen kann, also deren Buchwert einfach. Und Gold hat ja in dem Sinne keinen Buch wert. Gold ist ja nur Angebot und Nachfrage, was der Preis gerade dar.
Ja gut, aber aber Gold ist ja auch ein Werkstoff, der gefragt ist. Ich meine, es gibt ja kein kein Stück Elektronik auf dieser Welt, wo nicht Gold äh drauf ist. Also das ist ja nicht so, dass man mit Gold nichts anfangen könnte.
Stimmt äh genau, aber das ist ja von dem Gesamtgold, was irgendwie passiert ist, ist das natürlich nur ein geringer Betrag sozusagen, den du mit irgendwo verarbeitest. Dann hast du Recht, aber ein Großteil liegt ja irgendwo im im Safe oder sonstwo rum.
Warren Buffetter mal gesagt, finden uns Außerirdische ausm All beobachten würden, die würden ja denken, wir haben sie nicht mehr alle. Da gibt's irgendwo einen Bagger irgendwo in weiß ich nicht, Südafrika, die buddeln irgendwas aus wie das Gold, dann wird's per Schiff irgendwo nach Europa ähm äh verschifft und dann wird's hier wieder irgendwo im Safe gelegt und verbuddelt, ne. Also es ist ja,
so ein bisschen bisschen schizophren halt. Aber,
Letztendlich ist hier der es ist ja nur der Glaube daran, dass das Gold diesen Wert hat, weil es irgendwie begrenzt ist und weil es eben nicht vermehrt werden kann, weil sie wir keine chemische äh Nachbauten davon haben können und es nur limitierten Form, wie viel wir aus dem Boden holen können und,
Je höher der Preis das ist, desto mehr lohnt sich, danach tiefer zu buddeln. Wenn der Preis fällt, hört's immer mal auf mit dem Buddel,
Recht, es gibt irgendwie einen kleinen Industriepart, aber ein Großteil davon ist natürlich dafür da, um das Immun liegt. Und das Gleiche gilt ja auch für Bitcoin.
Irgendwie eine Rechner-Armee, ich glaube so ein paar NVIDIA-Grafikkarten und äh schürfe das Ganze. Das lohnt sich nur solange ähm wenn der Preis hoch ist und ich meine Stromkosten und meine Hardware mitdecken kann, fällt der Preis so wie grade jetzt, na ja, jetzt lohnt sich nicht, grade so wirklich Schiffen.
Lohnt sich, immer ein zu haben oder meinem oder wo auch immer. Ähm solange ich dran glaube, dass halt begrenzt ist.
Aber letztendlich nur der Glaube dadran. Bei BMW gibt's eine Standsanlage, die kann ich jetzt nehmen und am Markt sicherlich irgendwo verkaufen, kriege Geld X dafür, das ist der Buchwert.
Nur glauben, das andere ist seit Essens.
Die Aktie so weitergeht, müsst ihr das auch machen.
Also ein anderes Thema, genau. Aber das wollte ich nur sagen, das ist der Unterschied zwischen das meine ich mit inneren Wert. Das sind halt,
bei dir zu Hause jetzt auch Buchwerte, das ist dein dein Schreibtisch, dein dein Computer und irgendwie weiß ich nicht, vielleicht hast du irgendwie ein Podcast-Platent angemeldet und das hat auch noch einen gewissen Wert oder.
Ich ich glaube mit meinem äh,
mit dem Pferd meines Unternehmens so ein bisschen mit Gold. Da muss man auch dran glauben.
So, das ist der Unterschied.
Bist doch der goldene Kern.
Es hat natürlich auch eine gewisse Anwendung, ne? Also auch wie äh Gold. Also ich äh bin ja bei Gold nicht ganz so bei dir, ne, also allein was Gold schon äh so für für Schmuck äh und so weiter für eine für eine Bedeutung hat, also dass es da keine keine Wertschätzung.
Ja? Äh ist nicht so, dass die Leute sagen könnten so, ach Gold brauchen wir nicht, morgen gibt's nicht mehr. So, ja wenn's wenn's kein Bitcoin gibt, ändert sich auf diesem Planeten nichts.
Du keine goldene Halskette trägst, ändert sich auch nichts.
Ja, aber das ist halt etwas, was Leute haben wollen, aber die Leute wollen ja nicht per se Bitcoin haben, sondern wir wollen ja nur Geld verdienen. So, ob das so oder so heißt und irgendwie Bits oder äh andere Anlagen sind, ist im Prinzip komplett,
austauschbar. Das ist das, was ich meine mit, dass ich sie halt nicht sehe, dass es äh einen Wert in sich hat.
Ich kenne ganz viele Leute, die Millionen von Geld in Bitcoin geparkt haben, aber mit der Argumentation na ja in in Gold kann ich's eben nicht lagern, weil das eine Million in Gold zu
verschiffen und am Arm zu klemmen, ist ja relativ schwierig. Also wenn du morgen flüchten musst und kannst auf einen USB-Stick da in eine Million mitnehmen, hatten schon einen gewissen Cha.
Was kennst du denn für Leute, die sich darüber Gedanken machen in Millionen.
Heißen die Sam.
Es gibt so Leute, die sicherlich solche
Probleme haben, aber ich denke halt nicht, dass es ein riesen Markt ist. Die meisten Leute äh sind ja nicht im im,
Kryptogeld oder Krypto-Asset-Markt, um ihre Millionen zu speichern
Soll, ja, weil ich glaube, dass äh sieht man ja jetzt auch, dass man letztes Jahr mit angefangen hast, ja,
da hast du irgendwie dein Vermögen schon mal äh ordentlich halbiert bekommen.
Aber du kannst es gut mitnehmen, vor allem jetzt.
Es ist ja es ist ja ein sehr volatiles Gut so, das weiß man auch so und wenn wenn man jetzt wirklich äh denkt, man könnte hier langfristig Gewinne erzielen, okay gut, das,
kann ja sein, aber dann ist es halt auch nur ein Glaube
der äh primär genährt ist von so einem Hype und äh der Darstellung, dass das Ganze ja irgendwann mal tolle Anwendungen findet, nur dass ich ja bisher keine anderen Anwendungen gefunden haben außer genau diese Spekulation zu machen.
Versuche jetzt mal ein bisschen zusammenfassen, zusammenzufassen, was also was hier die die Pole sind ja mit Gold kann man auch etwas machen, der größere Teil von Gold wird aber nicht verwendet, ne, sondern irgendwo hingelagert, weil man davon ausgeht, dass man den nochmal verkaufen kann. Also es wird,
mehr sehr viel mehr Gold als Wertanlage irgendwo eingelagert.
Als Gold irgendwo tatsächlich gebraucht wird, um einen Kontakt zu vergolden oder eine Kettchen zu machen. Ähm,
dem gegenüber stehen Dinge, die man für das gleiche Geld kaufen kann, zum Beispiel Haus,
oder eine Wohnung, die irgendwie einen Nutzwert haben, ne. Land, das äh wo man was drauf anbauen kann, ja, die also einen erkennbaren
nicht vergänglichen Nutzwert haben, der natürlich auch Schwankungen unterliegt, je nachdem, wo das Haus, das Grundstück oder die Wohnung ist, ja oder,
wir grade äh Getreide in Deutschland äh produzieren wollen oder nicht und wie der Weltmarkt aussieht, aber das hat einen grundsätzlich irgendwie einen anwendbaren Nutzen. Und wenn der Daniel jetzt hingeht und kauft äh Aktien von einem Unternehmen
dann tut er das.
Weil er die Sicherheit mag oder daran glaubt, dass dieses Unternehmen weiterhin existieren wird und nicht, weil er das Stück Papier auf dem steht, das ihm das äh Unternehmen gehört so schön findet,
Ich glaube, das ist der Punkt, den du äh den du machen möchtest und bei bei Währungen.
Die haben ja auch keinen und jetzt kommen wir du hast wieder das ist alles nichts wert, ne? Ja es stimmt ja auch, aber irgendwie ähm behält es seinen Wert als universelles Austauschgut.
Also ich glaube darauf,
darauf wollte Daniel so ein bisschen hinaus. Also wir sind nicht über die Details von von Gold oder Nichtgold, sprechen auf jeden Fall hast du,
Tim mit Gold können wir am Ende wenigstens noch Kontakte vergolden, das wird mit Bitcoin schwer.
Ja vielleicht nochmal, ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr vertiefen, aber ich habe kurz nochmal nachgeschlagen äh wie was eigentlich wirklich die gol,
ist pro Jahr auf der Welt, ja und äh tatsächlich wird der Großteil,
in der Schmuckindustrie gebraucht und der ist höher als das was über Minen produziert wird. Das heißt die Nachfrage wird derzeit im Wesentlichen äh dann eben auch
auch mit Zentralbankverkäufen gemacht und also äh Schmuck zweitausendzweihunderteinundzwanzig,
2221 Tonnen Investment 000 Tonnen Industrieverbrauch 330 Tonnen und die Zentralbanken 463 Tonnen. Also tatsächlich ist,
im Wesentlichen Schmuck, Produktion und und die Industrieproduktion schon mal ein Vielfaches größer als der Rest. Das mal so zur.
Wertlosigkeit von Gold. Aber ich will das jetzt gar nicht weiter vertiefen.
Aber da da hängt das so ein bisschen. Ich meine, aber der Schmuck ist doch letztendlich nichts anderes. Du könntest dir ja auch irgendwie eine Kette aus irgendwie Papier kaufen, die auch schön aussieht. So, ich meine, es gibt einen Grund, warum du dir eine Goldkette kaufst, weil letztendlich, wenn du auch morgen flüchten musst, kannst du wahrscheinlich damit auch unbedingt ein Brot kaufen oder so was,
Also sie geht ja nie, es geht ja nicht nur um Optik, sondern es geht auch um den Wert. Und die Goldkette ist ja umso teurer, je wert, je höher der Goldpreis ist.
Ja klar, aber das ist ja eine eine wirtschaftliche Wertschöpfung, ne. Leute verdienen damit, äh irgendwie das das ist im Umlauf et cetera und liegt nicht nur auf irgendwelchen Servern.
NVIDIA verdient auch an an Bitcoin, indem sie Grafikkarten verkaufen, ist auch eine Wertschöpf.
Aber die Gamer nicht, die kriegen nämlich keine.
Ja die bringen ja auch keinem was. Die sollen mal arbeiten.
Die sollen sich mal hier an der an der Mehrwert äh äh Generierung äh beteiligen.
Okay, also kurz gesagt, du denkst, äh du denkst, dass äh das äh Gespenst wird so schnell nicht äh vom Markt verschwinden, aber wir können durchaus jetzt kurzfristig noch ein paar Crashs sehen, gerade in der Folge von der ganzen FDX-Problematik.
Glaube ich zum einen und ich glaube, den Punkt ist, den wir jetzt gerade hatten, also Gold, was Jara, zehn oder Jahrhunderte galt und gilt
in Krisenzeiten kann ich mich mit absichern. Das hatte man auch dem dem Bitcoin zugeschrieben und jetzt sehen wir's ja grad am Markt, dass es ja nicht so eingetroffen. So die Frage ist ja, was wird daraus,
gerade über Wirtschaftlichkeit nochmal gesprochen, wenn wir jetzt auf diese dezentralisierten äh Token gehen, die auf stattfinden,
kann natürlich schon nochmal ein wirtschaftlicher 2g werden. Ähm indem ich halt wie wie sagt darüber irgendwie Dinge,
die vielleicht im Finanzsystem stattfinden, ich dann dort günstiger Abbildung vielleicht irgendwie nicht so hohe Gebühren bezahlen muss,
oder du,
morgen ähm ein Auto per Kredit und zahlst deine ähm dein Kreditrate nicht und das Schloss deines Autos geht nicht mehr auf. Auch das würde dir ja theoretisch alles mitbildbar sein,
Das ist vielleicht kein Nutzen so riesengroß, aber ja.
Goldpreis ist auf jeden Fall gestiegen.
Ich äh ich es gibt einen sehr schönen äh Vortrag von ähm Fefe, den er vor einiger Zeit mal hier in der Finanzindustrie gehalten hat, hätte ich hier sogar in Frankfurt. Äh vielleicht könnte ich meine Show Notes irgendwie verlinken,
fand ich sehr amüsant, also logischerweise viel für der durch dann in einer Stunde daliegt alles äh auseinandergenommen hat,
Direktion aber in dem Publikum fand ich irgendwie ganz interessant, die dann doch irgendwie manche Gesichtszüge doch entgleist sind. Also ich könnte mir vielleicht mal verlinken den die die die Präsentation.
So dann äh können wir vielleicht mal von dem allgemeinen Krypto äh Thema auf äh das Twitter-Thema. Es gibt da auch eine Verbindung äh hast du gesagt, ne? Zwischen Sam Bankman Freed und Twitter.
Hat tatsächlich mal also weit vorher zumindest äh wo es noch nicht öffentlich war, drüber nachgedacht hat, auch äh tatsächlich Twitter zu kaufen. Ähm,
hat es dann aber nicht gemacht. Ähm man wusste jetzt nicht so genau richtig, warum,
aber im Zuge dessen wurde dann Elon Must aufge äh aufgestiegen ist auf diesem Zug und wollte es dann kaufen, hat er sich angeboten denn das Ganze mit äh zu zu finanzieren,
Bereit in der Übernahme zwischen 8 bis 15 Milliarden auszugeben. Das äh hat er wohl zugesichert.
Zu lange Zeit erst keinen direkten Draht zu Elon Musk. Es ging alles über einen äh Investmentbanker, dann bei Morgan Stanley.
Ähm Elon hat das dann wohl ein bisschen abgetan bei dem Investmentbanker, sagt, na ja, er hätte eigentlich im Endeffekt keine Lust ihn reinzuholen, weil er dann nur Diskussionen über Blockchain und so was führen möchte und daher da keine Lust drauf. Das war eine Antwort gewesen.
Wohl doch auch nochmal Chatnachrichten und das war aber glaube ich eher ein Scherz von Elo Mars, der hat einen gefragten Chat, sag mal ähm also er hat,
nochmal Geld angeboten, hat er gesagt, sag mal, wer bist du eigentlich? Hat jemand so ein bisschen ignoriert und somit ist dann durch da erstmal als Stil nicht zustande gekommen und damit war's ganz vom Tisch.
So, der einzige von uns, der jemals Twitter gekauft hat bisher du? Oder Thema hast du mal hast du mal Twitter gekauft.
Ich ich habe kein Twitter gekauft. Ich habe auch kein Gold gekauft, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich habe nur gekauft.
Shit.
Wie ich so eine tolle Idee.
Ähm war vielleicht fangen wir mal mit der Frage an. Wann hast du Twitter gekauft.
Und warum? Daniel, das ey ich finde das ja tatsächlich spannend. Also vielleicht kann man also wann bist du da mit deinem Fond eingestiegen und mit welcher also aus welchen Begründungen? Weil du nimmst ja.
Tim lacht nur.
Gleich klarstellen, dass Daniel natürlich nicht das gesamte twitter gekauft hat so. Nur ein paar Aktien.
Nur einen kleinen Anteil.
So, aber warum.
Also Twitter klar äh begleite mich schon lange, kenne es lange als Unternehmen. Mhm es gab mal eine Zeit, oh zwotausendvierzehn, da wo ähm.
Square gerade frisch gegründet ist, ähm äh dass ich Jack Dorsey häufiger getroffen habe. Da waren wir ein bisschen zugänglicher gewesen. Ähm.
Ich glaube, ich erinnere mich an erste Meetings mit ihm, wo ich eben in San Francisco mit ihm im Park spazieren war und wir Pizza gegessen haben. Na gut, die Zeiten sind vorbei. Jetzt antwortet er vielleicht nur noch auf jede zehnte E-Mail, wenn er überhaupt noch irgendwie antwortet,
Und da wir schon viel auch über Twitter diskutiert und all diese Fragen, die erzähle ich jetzt aufkommen, genau diese Fragen habe ich mit dem schon erörtert irgendwie vor zehn oder vor 15 Jahren. Ich persönlich bin eingestiegen, hm,
in der Phase, wo Trump ähm gesperrt wurde,
Und zwar hat der Aktienkurs daraufhin sehr stark nachgegeben. Die Begründung war naja okay, wenn Trump nicht mehr auf dieser Plattform ist, der natürlich viel für Tumult gesorgt. Das bringen Klicks und Werbegelder und so weiter,
Ich habe gesagt, nee und man konnte das auch irgendwie ein bisschen nachrechnen, dass der Effekt von Trump nicht,
groß sein wird, äh wie das, was die Aktie in dem Moment erstmal an an Kurs verloren hat, an Market gibt. Das war Schritt eins gewesen.
Schritt zwei in der Überlegung war und damit sind wir an einem Punkt, wie verdient man mit Twitter eigentlich denn wirklich Geld, weil das musste ich mir dann auch überlegen, ja, was kann man denn jetzt eigentlich besser machen,
Twitter hat's natürlich in der Vergangenheit ganz häufig ähm geloost.
Es hätte das nächste TikTok werden können. Man hatte irgendwie Wine gehabt, hat nicht so richtig funktioniert mit der Integration. Ähm hat auf Video gesetzt, hat man auch wieder eingestammt und so weiter.
Aber ein großes Problem für Twitter ja jahrelang war er gewesen, dass sie nur Brand Advertisment gemacht haben, also du konntest nur gewisse Marken bewerben, aber man konnte keine personalisierte Werbung machen, weil man dazu sich nicht in der Lage fand,
diese Daten hier auszuwerten und man hat jetzt auch nicht wie irgendwie andere wie Facebook und Co. Diese Daten da irgendwo von den Handys abgegriffen. Und das ist ja eigentlich das irrationale, dass man sagt, hm.
Mal behaupten, dass es das das Wichtigste, also bis vielleicht vor Elo-Maske oder vielleicht diskutieren, aber bis vor Elon Musk eins der wichtigsten Netzwerke waren also von der Relevanz her, denn jegliche Nachricht auf diesem Planeten finde ich tatsächlich als erstes bei Twitter.
Komischerweise, die Werbeindustrie sieht's komplett anders. Bei Facebook, wenn du schreibst irgendwie, ich habe mir heute mal neue Radkappen gekauft. Das war dem Werbemarkt mehr wert, weil da Leute mehr geklickt haben und du mehr die Interessen wusstest. Das war lange Zeit das Problem von Twitter.
In dem Zug, wo ich eingestiegen bin, gab's aber die Bewegung dorthin und darum hat man auch so viele Leute eingestellt.
Dass man sagt, okay, wir verbessern uns in dem Sinne, dass wir jetzt anfangen mit Maschinenlearning. Die Leute besser zu verstehen, was sind denn die Interessen von Tim oder von Linus und wie können wir explizit maßgeschneidert dementsprechend Werbung äh.
Anzeigen. Das hat in Einzelzügen von Quartal zuckertal auch schon geklappt und das war auf einem sehr guten Weg gewesen,
mal einfach nimmt, was die Umsätze im Werbebereich waren, pro Nutzer, den man dort dann hatte, hat man gesehen, dass der also der April, der,
Everage Revenue per Nutzer sozusagen, sich über die Zeit entsprechend verdoppelt hat. Also mein warte schon auf einem guten Weg gewesen und das war der zweite Grund, warum ich sage, das das bewegt sich in die richtige Richtung.
Der dritte Grund war, das war so ein bisschen eine Überlegung zu sagen.
Was es immer noch nicht gibt, ist ein Streaming-Dienst rein nur für News. Also meine Überlegung war zu sagen, warum kauft ihr nicht CNN Twitter oder Twitter CNN? Und da macht man ein Streaming, ein ein Streaming-Dienst,
also wie wie Netflix, wo es nur reine News gibt. Ich glaube, dafür gibt's gewisse use cases und das hätte man sicherlich nie so aufstellen können. Das war Punkt drei,
Punkt 4 am Ende ist natürlich, dass es verdammt viele Leute auf der Plattform gibt, die irgendwie Dinge,
kreieren, aber man das dann nicht irgendwie in der Wertschöpfung nicht mit dran beteiligt ist. Man hätte ja auch sagen können, irgendwie man macht so was wie Substrat, ähm Newsletter-Angebot, aber verdient entsprechend mit daran,
kann man nicht jetzt auch Twitter ähm die ganzen,
Universum und NFTs und so weiter hätte man ja auch Geld mit verdienen können,
Überlegung ähm gibt's jetzt ja auch ähm warum könnte nicht jetzt Elomast in die FDX kaufen und irgendwie Bitcoins oder Kryptowährungen äh installieren, auch das wären durch einen Bereich gewesen,
Beschluss der andere Bereich, warum nicht auch noch mal E-Commerce mit anbieten. Ähm finde ich Schuhe auf Instagram kaufe, ähm könnte ich's ja vielleicht auch unter Umständen bei Twitter halt machen.
So die Überlegung,
Gespräche mit Management zeigen, dass man in diese Richtung halt irgendwie ging und die Zahlen zeigt, dass es in die richtige Richtung ging, das war der Stand der Dinge. Bis eines Tages Elon Must auf den Plan kam.
Du hast mit jetzt äh so Leuten wie Jack Dorsey, also der äh einer der Gründer auch von Twitter ist, ne, genau,
Bis vor Kurzem äh auch noch äh CEO war, also ich weiß nicht, aber es ist schon länger nicht oder jetzt erst durch den Kauf von von von Musk.
Vorher hatte man ihn rausgedrängt. Äh das das auch ganz lustig, Hedgefonds und Co haben gesagt, ähm wir kaufen's große Stücke von Twitter und als einer der Punkte auf unserer Liste ist Jack, wir wollen dich nicht mal CEO haben, weil es ist ja unmöglich, dass ein Mann oder eine Frau ist, gleich,
zwei Unternehmen als CEO führt. Lustigerweise haben wir jetzt aber Elon Musk, der irgendwie wie viel Unternehmen führt, also dazu.
Aber okay aber dafür gehört's auch denen nicht mehr, ne, diesen Fonds. Dafür gehört sie.
Ja genau.
Alleine machen
Die denen die anderen Unternehmen äh den Anteil an den anderen Unternehmen gehören scheinen auch gar nicht so begeistert davon zu sein. Das ist der Typ, von dem sie sich fette
Tesla Millionen erhoffen sich gerade irgendwie 4undzwanzig7 bei Twitter zum zum Horst macht, oder.
Definitiv, ich meine auch zurecht. Ich meine, wenn ich mir die Anzahl seiner Tweets angucke, frage ich mich, wie Mensch er das von der Zeit her, also er scheint da mehr Zeit im Internet zu verbringen als alles andere halt.
Ich habe gerade kurz erwähnt, ich glaube da wolltest du darauf hinaus Tim zu sagen, was war denn die Diskussion mit Jack Dorsey und meine Idee war, habe ich schon von vornherein immer gewesen, ich glaube diese diese ganze Werbeapparat ist das Falsche für Twitter und das ist schon immer meine Meinung gewesen
glaube, man hätte schon frühzeitig sagen sollen.
Werbung, nee will ich nicht, die Leute sollen einfach, weiß ich, drei Dollar im Monat für den Dienst komplett bezahlen. Und die Antwort vor 1 Jahren war darauf, ja, wird er auch so sehen, aber wenn ich das mache, könnte man Unternehmen morgen pleite sein, weil ich nicht weiß, ob sie's Leute wirklich wollen oder nicht.
Gleichen Frage steht wahrscheinlich jetzt auch Elo Musk.
Ich meine, was was ist denn die wirkliche Stärke von Twitter? Ich meine, es ist hier sicherlich nicht.
Also das ist jetzt ein bisschen dispektierlich, aber ich meine, Twitter kann man wahrscheinlich in einer Woche bauen, können's vielleicht nur drei Leute nutzen. Und ich meine, in dem Maße, wie sie's dann aufgebaut haben, klar, es muss auf auf gewissen Servern nämlich skalierbar sein. Es muss einen Ansturm aushalten,
das, was man im Zuge drüber aufgebaut hat, ist ähm zu sagen, wie moderiere ich den Content? Es hat sicherlich auch einen Wert,
um vielleicht Werbung besser auszuloten wem kann ich was wie zu zu schustern das hat alles noch nicht seinen gewissen Wert, aber,
Die wirkliche Stärke ist ja von Twitter dieser aus meiner Meinung diese Universität Universität.
Also die Anwesenheit von Politikern, Prominenten auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite Journalisten, Forscher und so weiter, die natürlich eben im Austausch stehen. Also ich als Journalist weiß, ich finde dort die Meinung von X und kann darüber schreiben und ich habe einen Prominenten, der auch bereit ist, diese Leute irgendwie kundzutun,
von dieser Plattform nach und nach verschwinden, verliert auch die Plattform ihren Wert. Selbst wenn immer noch 80 Prozent Leute da bleiben, aber wenn die weg sind, dann hat's auch keine Bedeutung mehr.
Ich denke auch, dass diese Meinungsführerschaft, die dort immer wieder neu ausgewürfelt wird, äh ein Großteil des äh Interesses äh ausmacht, ne und auch wenn
wird dann nie mit diesem selben Nutzerzahlen halt wedeln können wie Facebook. Haben sie halt schon einen sehr spezifische Nutzer äh,
Gruppe angezogen so
Und tut das ja auch nach wie vor, ne? Die Leute äh sind ja alle deshalb gerade auch so ein bisschen in Panik, weil sie eben Angst haben, dass ihnen da wirklich ein ein ein wichtiges Werkzeug, was die Arbeit der letzten zehn, 12 Jahre geprägt hat, äh auf einmal,
sich in Luft auflösen könnte, ne, ohne dass es äh wirklich eine gute direkte unmittelbare Alternative dazu gibt.
Ich wollte nochmal kurz nachfragen. Also du hast ja mit deshalb getroffen, weil du quasi so als Investor da aufgetreten bist, so nach dem Motto hier, ich,
habe mal in größerem Maße hier Aktien gekauft und dann äh kriegt man schon auch Zugriff auf auf solche Leute. Wie hast du die denn so empfunden, also als was für einen Typ muss man sie, weil der ist ja auch ein so ein etwas.
Spezieller Kandidat, sage ich mal, so, ne, äh dessen dessen ähm.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie man mit Jack Dorsey durch den Park geht und der andauernd einen Dollar kriegt oder so.
Ja aber kannst du vielleicht mal so ein bisschen uns mal zu schildern so was für eine Art Charakter äh das jetzt
ist und zwar nicht so sehr, um jetzt spezifisch genau ihn jetzt auszuleuchten, sondern überhaupt so diese Garde von ähm Silicon Valley, Superleuten, die irgendwie solche crazy Projekte äh vorantreiben.
Im Zuge damals weiß er nicht der der Twitter Investitions ging um dies Querinvestitionen letztendlich. Ich meine da war's noch super klein. Da hast du ja Zukunft auf solche Leute. Je größer dann auch es quer wurde, hast du natürlich niemals mehr mit ihm gesprochen, sondern dann hat er natürlich dann installierten Stab an Leuten, die mit dir reden
Das heißt, je größer und mehr Geld im Spiel ist, desto mehr erziehen sich die Leute logischerweise auch zurück. Also jetzt nicht Gang und gäbe.
Also Squerweide sozusagen das andere Unternehmen, was er gegründet hat.
Genau richtig. Ähm ich glaube auch, dass sich auch über die Zeit auch eher natürlich eine Persönlichkeitsentwicklung wahrscheinlich vorgenommen hat, so wie ich das feststelle, also wie du's grad schon sagst. Ich glaube, der ist natürlich von Grund auf irgendwie Entwickler und hat natürlich eher einen Charakter, der irgendwie eher sehr zurückhaltend ist,
er war schon immer sehr sehr reflektiert gewesen. Er hatte schon irgendwie einen sehr guten Blick auf auf die Welt und konnte Dinge relativ gut einschätzen.
Aber da manchmal auch gebissen mit dem, was dann vielleicht wirklich Investoren wollten, also er hat's glaube ich nicht in dem Maße umgesetzt, was wirklich seine seine innerliche Haltung vielleicht zu manchen Dingen ist.
Ich glaube mit der Zeit klar die spielen natürlich auch Geld eine Rolle wenn man jetzt nochmal im Nachgang immer mit ihm auch Meetings irgendwie hatte die dann virtuell waren die bei einem größeren Kreis waren,
war schon sehr speziell und dann war auch meistens sehr ruhig gewesen in vielen Calls war vielleicht so ein Redeanteil zehn Prozent und der größte Teil war dann doch seine Managementleute.
Meistens hat ja dann relativ viele, also die sich um die Finanzen kümmern, die waren ja von Goldman Sachsen so weiter gewesen, die natürlich auch wussten, wie man da mit dem Finanzmarkt halten wir umgeht. Ich glaube, dadurch dann mehr und mehr zurückgehalten.
Aber per se glaube ich, wie gesagt, war's A-schüchtern und B sehr, sehr reflektiert, aber hat glaube ich nicht immer das gemacht, was er wirklich irgendwie aufm Herzen getragen hat, sondern war dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen geleitet vom Finanz.
Eine Sache hat er ja gemacht, die ich sehr äh auch interessant fand. Er hat ja offenbar jetzt eine Minderbeteiligung an Twitter unter Musk.
Also er hätte ihm natürlich auch seine Anteile verkaufen können, aber hat ihm hat quasi gesagt, nee, nee, komm, lass mich mal da einfach drin stehen. Du übernimmst hier die anderen neunundneunzig Prozent oder so und hat dem Musk damit irgendwie eine Milliarde oder sowas gespart.
Meinst du, der ist da jetzt happy mit der Entscheidung? Also warum hat er es getan.
Also tatsächlich gibt es ähm Gerüchte, wonach Jack Dors hier sogar Elon Mustimi zu überredet hat, irgendwie die Anteile zu übernehmen oder beziehungsweise das Unternehmen zu übernehmen. Ähm ich glaube, dass er schon dachte, dass es eine gute Idee ist,
Und ich glaube natürlich auch im Zuge dessen, dass er bisher das Geld nie abgezogen hat, war natürlich auch irgendwie also die nötige Glaubwürdigkeit, dass sie auch irgendwie Aktionäre mit an Bord zunächst erstmal bleiben. Ähm.
Was er jetzt denkt? Ich meine, bei Twitter sieht man manchmal die Diskussion von beiden, aber die sind gehen beide in die gleiche Richtung, da sehe ich jetzt irgendwie keinen Discos oder so was.
In in welche Richtung.
Die Diskussion geben, meint ihr, oder.
Also ich habe tatsächlich, ich also ich habe jetzt nicht fest oder ich bin mir keiner Diskussion oder keine Äußerung zwischen Elon Musk und Jack Dorsy bewusst. Kann sein, dass es ihm gar nicht folge.
Es geht nicht explizit rein um Twitter-Dinge. Ich glaube, da äußerte sich Jack Dorsey nicht zu, aber wenn's allgemein darum geht, wir brauchen viel mehr Freiheit auf der Plattform und im und so weiter. Ich glaube, dem stimmt Jack Dorsey halt irgendwie entsprechend genauso zu.
Man hat ja, das ist ja auch der Punkt. Ich meine, Trump,
hat man erst dann gesperrt, nachdem wieder Angriffs aufs Kapitol war. Man hat's ja etliche Jahre ausgehalten. Ich glaube, dass man sich auch bei Twitter auch bewusst war, dass man ihn natürlich auch so ein bisschen gebraucht hat, wenn man ganz ehrlich ist.
Gebraucht hat oder Angst hatte vor ihm. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Es kann auch sein, ja das stimmt, ja.
Das alles äh sehr undurchsichtig. Kommen wir doch mal kurz zu Elon Musk, was äh denkst du denn jetzt, was aus diesem Produkt äh wird äh wird es denn jetzt zerstört werden deiner Meinung nach oder was passiert.
Also Elon Must, ich meine alle bezeichnen ihn als Genie. Ich glaube so wie er sich grad benimmt, so benimmt sich, glaube ich, kein Genie. Also das bezweifle ihm wie stark dran.
Ich meine, also Twitter hatte ja ähm bis wo es die Finanzzahl noch gab bis zum zweiten Quartal 2022 die Zahlen draußen und man kamen so ungefähr auf eine Milliarde Cashflow.
Jetzt ist natürlich Twitter eine Menge Kredi,
geheizt worden, wenn ich's richtig verstanden habe, nehme ich diese 13 Milliarden, das heißt ist halt natürlich typisch für so ein private Bereich,
über die Zeit abgetragen werden müssen, das heißt hat schon massiv Druck natürlich, dass das Unternehmen da irgendwie Geld verdient und Cashflow-Randschaft, um auch die Medikredite halt zu bedienen,
Marcel hat angedeutet, er will ihm eine Milliarde an Kosten rausnehmen.
Es wird natürlich irgendwie schwierig. Man hat, glaube ich, jetzt vor einigen Jahren mal irgendwie zu zu AWS gewechselt. Man hat gar keine eigenen Datencenter mehr in der Form,
Kostet eben zwischen 1,5 bis3 Millionen irgendwie pro Tag. Sie fragt man da noch Kosten rausnehmen kann.
Irgendwie zur Hälfte irgendwie entlassen oder nicht eine Programmiere oder eine Menge Leute. Klar, das spart auch mal ein bisschen was.
Die Frage, was passiert natürlich damit ist Security? Ganz viele sagen, dass man da besser seine Daten erstmal runterzieht und sich keine private Nachrichten schreibt. Ähm.
Vielen Dingen frage ich mich, wie sehr es Elomas wirklich technisch versiert. Also er will irgendwie auf der äh bei den Direct Messages auf der Plattform irgendwie ähm Enterend-Message äh äh Verschlüsselung einführen. Stelle ich mir ein bisschen schwierig vor, zumindest im Browser. Ich glaube, das funktioniert eher nicht.
Als als Programmierer ist man natürlich auch im sehr gut vernetzt. Also wenn man denen die vergrault, die werden jetzt auch nicht irgendwie wiederkommen, selbst wenn er damit Geldscheinwedelt. Also das stelle ich mir alles relativ schwierig vor.
Die Werbekunden sieht man, laufen eben natürlich weg, also der Druck erhöht sich von Tag zu Tag und ich fürchte fast, dass es eher gegen die Wand läuft. Also entweder ist es wirklich so, dass es ihm mal nächstes Jahr pleite geht,
oder er findet jemanden, der es vielleicht für einen kleineren Taler irgendwie übernimmt.
Sind eher so meine beiden Szenarien, worauf es hinauslaufen kann.
Ist das überhaupt vorstellbar, dass Twitter äh wirklich abgeschaltet wird.
Geht doch ganz schnell aus.
Noch nicht mal selber zu machen.
Also mir mir ist schon klar, dass das theoretisch äh und auch praktisch natürlich stattfinden kann so, ne? Und wenn es halt
wirklich äh so weit getrieben wird, dass Elon Mass sagt auch jetzt habe ich aber den Spaß dran verloren und das brauchen wir auch nicht mehr. Jetzt schalten wir das einfach ab. Dann
kann ihn da im Prinzip daran gar keiner hindern. Er schmeißt einfach alle raus und dann war's das, ne.
Ich glaube ja schon, dass der dass der ein bisschen auch an seinem Geld hängt, ne. Also es hat ihnen jetzt nicht die die die also es hat ihn jetzt nicht die kompletten 44 Milliarden da gekostet. Der hat sich das ja auch
nur geliehen dieses Geld, ne? Und am Ende das Unternehmen selber noch damit belastet, aber er hat einen signifikanten Teil Testeraktien verkauft
und ähm ich glaube nicht, dass er ähm.
Dass er unbeschadet aus der Nummer rauskommt, ja? Also wenn.
Auf eine Weise ist es ja wirklich tragisch. Der wollte das Unternehmen ja wirklich nicht kaufen und.
Wenn man sich anschaut, wie das da jetzt wie destelliert, wie es jetzt da steht.
Dann hatte er auch ganz offensichtlich keinen Plan. Also meine meine Theorie, dass er irgendwie im Rausch,
gesagt hat ja geil ich kaufe jetzt Twitter welchen Rausch auch immer.
Und dann irgendwie gecheckt hat, ach Scheiße, ich habe hier was unterschrieben, dass ich's wirklich machen muss und dann in irgendeinen anderen Rausch gesagt hat, na ja okay, bevor ich jetzt eine Milliarde Strafe zahle und es nicht mache,
nehme ich lieber ein paar Milliarden in die Hand und mach's, weil ich bin ja die geilste Sau und bisher ist alles zu Gold geworden, was ich angefasst habe, bis auf äh na ja ein paar andere Dinge.
Weiß nicht.
Also es äh der hat ja offensichtlich keinen Plan. Also er kann ja nicht da reingehen, dann wirft er die Hälfte der Leute raus. Dann sagt er, bis morgen macht er dieses und jenes. Dann fällt ihm auf, oh habe ich komplett verkackt,
Habe ich komplett verkackt, völlig überraschend ähm konnte ich nicht über Nacht äh sagen, für 8 Euro,
für acht Dollar bis hier verifizierte Account, ohne dass es Missbrauch.
Und irgendwie kann ich diesen Verifikationskram jetzt auch nicht mehr aufrechterhalten, wo ich alle rausgeworfen habe und er ist ja jetzt noch
dadran, ja? Muss man sich ja auch mal überlegen.
CEO Attention, er twittert jetzt gerade so sein letzter Tweet ist, ja, Twitter wird jetzt schneller.
Äh äh in es gibt jetzt Verbesserungen bei Twitter in der Geschwindigkeit. Also.
Wie wir wissen, ne, wir haben uns die ganze Zeit sitzen wir bei Twitter und ärgern uns, dass es nicht schnell genug geht.
Das hätte jetzt vor zehn Stunden so CEO attention,
So ich meine der sollte sich lieber mal darüber also über alles sollte der sich Gedanken machen, ne? Man hat ja da irgendwie seine Tester Developer reingeholt und wie du ja auch schon sagtest Daniel als wenn der Laden als wenn der Wert dieses Unternehmens wäre, dass es schnell ist.
Ich meine, die schicken 280 Zeichen,
wie schnell sollen es denn noch machen.
Also die eine Sache, die für mich nie langsam war, war Twitter,
Eine Sache, die wo ich nie gesagt habe, boah, der muss aber jetzt schneller sein bei Twitter. Liegt daran, dass ich äh seit ungefähr wahrscheinlich den 90er Jahren ausreichend Bandbreite für Twitter habe. Selbst in Deutschland.
Spannend fand ich ein Tipp von ihm heute Nacht, indem er ein ein Bild oder ein ein Graf postete, wo er nachsagt, hate speech impression allour. Ähm vielleicht jetzt hier Oktober mit November, wo es jetzt von zehn Millionen irgendwie auf zweieinhalb Millionen runtergeht,
Erster Gedanke war, na ja, wenn er das doch die Impression messen kann von Hate Speech, dann kann man's doch auch abstellen oder? Also wenn ich's messen kann, dann kann ich's so irgendwie löschen.
Ich denke, er hat vor allem dir einfach die Definition geändert, oder.
Ja vielleicht.
Ja also ist die große Frage, was für ihn irgendwie Hate Speech ist und auch dieses ganze Free Speech Gelaber finde ich halt auch irgendwie äh total verstörend, weil es halt irgendwie sehr unklar ist, was damit nun wirklich gemeint ist, ne.
Ich glaube, dass Elon Mars selber ein sehr guter Ingenieur ist und es ist für ihn einfacher oder es ist für ihn einfach Autos zu bauen, Raketen zu bauen und ich glaube, was er, ich aus meiner Meinung, vielleicht verwechselt ist dies.
Wenn ich jetzt Tesla Autos baue und stelle meine Fabrik fest, um es die Produktion hakt an dieser Stelle,
kann ich sie vielleicht mal ausschalten und was ich attestiere den Roboter neu oder was auch immer. Ähm aber es hat keine Rückwirkung auf die bestehende Autoflotte auf der Straße. Die Kasper sind weiterhin happy und fahren dieses Auto
Die merken zwangsweise nichts davon, außer der der vielleicht eins bestellt hat, der es vielleicht drei Wochen später bekommt. Aber ich glaube, das geht eben bei Software halt eben nicht,
vorwirkend in einem sozialen Netzwerk rum und alles was er da macht,
direkt Auswirkung auf die bestehenden Kastnamerbasis. Und ich glaube, das,
Ist der Unterschied zwischen Software Design versus Engineering im im Raketenbereich oder Autobereich.
Also ich meine auch bei
Tesla gibt es Softwareauswirkungen und wenn da äh morgen irgendein Feature äh online,
dann hat das auch Auswirkung auf die und sowas gab's ja nun auch schon, ne? Hatten wir ja auch schon paar mal
gehabt so mit irgendwelchen freigeschalteten Sachen und dann wird das weiter verkauft und so weiter. Also äh ganz so würde ich's jetzt nicht darstellen, aber ich
ich weiß, worauf du hinaus willst. Äh man könnte vielleicht mal anders zusammenfassen, ein Social Network
lebt einfach sehr viel mehr von von von den Leuten und was sie eben denken und fühlen und das ist eben nicht so eine klare äh Produkt-Feature äh
sondern hier lebst du sozusagen mit den Menschen und es ist noch etwas unklar, ob die Psyche von Elon Musk dafür eigentlich wirklich.
Wenn er das vielleicht selber geglaubt hat, weil er eben selber auch so ein Twitter Rati äh ist und so ein Wahnsinniger, der irgendwie da total drauf abfährt.
Für die für die für die Chronik müssen wir noch erwähnen, dass er ja dann diese also dann hat er er macht jetzt Entscheidungen bei Twitter über dieses Poll-Feature, was mein äh Kleinen nicht unterstützt, da muss ich immer nochmal auf die Webseite gehen.
Sauber abstimmen lassen. Ähm wer äh also ob Donald Trump wieder auf Twitter kommen soll oder nicht,
und hat also einfach ein Poll, ja, nein und hat da druntergeschrieben, VOX,
D, also die Stimme des Volkes,
die Stimme Gottes und was sehr schön ist, ist ähm dass es in im Brief von.
Alins an Karl den Großen kommt dieser Satz äh als neunter Ratschlag vor,
DE
sorry. Tumulto Ositas vulgis in, was auf Deutsch heißt, auf diejenigen muss man nicht hören, die zu sagen pflegen, Volkes Stimme,
da die Lärmsucht des Pöbels immer dem Wahnsinn sehr nahe kommt.
Und dann.
Volltreffer, ey.
Und dann kommt halt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, zweiundfünfzig Prozent, ne, die ganzen Mager äh äh.
Haben dann halt gesagt, wir wollen Donald Trump wieder haben und dann hat er dann hat er gesagt, ja okay, machen wir,
Und dann twittert er dann hat jetzt Donald Trump äh hat bisher von diesem Twitter-Account noch keinen Gebrauch gemacht, ne. Hätte ich an Donald Trump Stelle auch nicht. Der wird jetzt warten.
Alle denken, also bis das abgeklungen ist, ja
mit irgendetwas wird er dann aus dem Nichts füttern, wenn der richtige Moment ist, ne? Es wird noch vielleicht eine Woche also es kann noch ein Tag
Wahrscheinlich aber eher zwei Wochen oder drei Wochen sein, das wird dann irgendwie sein, keine Ahnung, ne. Ich konnte die kandidiere oder irgendwas mit der wird sich schon den ganz großen Auftritt aufheben.
Wenn er wirklich so eine richtige, so einen richtigen Furz quer sitzen hat.
Es gibt einen, es gibt natürlich ein Argument, warum das auch auch dann nicht stattfinden würde.
Warum? Weil er das Passwort nicht mehr weiß.
Nein, weil er ja nun.
Weil er nun true social gegründet hat und das gehört ihm ja.
Ja, das ist super, dass True äh Social, ne, aber dann dann hier nur unters Niveau, ne, noch mal zu halten. Dann hat ja Elon Musk
irgendwie so ein Bild gezeigt vor äh oder getwittert von einer
also ich kenne kann das Originalbild jetzt nicht, aber vom also sagen wir von der weiblichen Sünde, die ihr Hinterteil einem Mönch entgegenstreckt und auf den
auf den Mönch hat er dann da irgendwie das Gesicht von Donald Trump gemacht und auf das Hinterteil irgendwie den den das Twitter-Logo.
Weißt du.
Das ist also das ist ein Niveau, was der erreicht, also dass nicht irgendjemand,
Thema mit so einem Nashornpfeil einfach mal eine Stunde schlafen legt, ja, weil der wirklich.
Durch.
Ja das das ist wirklich grenzwertig, also es ist äh.
Also es ist.
Unfassbar. Vor allem möchte ich gar nicht wissen, wie gegen wie viele der Twitter-Regel der eigentlich mittlerweile schon selber.
Kann ich auch äh so viel wie der Twitter hat, merkt er vielleicht echt, dass es nicht schnell genug ist, ne? Das könnte auch sein.
Also ich finde es wirklich ähm dramatisch anzuschauen und was ich glaube, was wirklich das Oberdrama ist.
Also unter der Annahme, dass der dass der Mann gerade nicht ganz nicht ganz bei Sinnen ist, ja
Natürlich jetzt auf die Zahlen schaut und merkt, boah Alter, die reden ja über Twitter, das das hat ja noch nie. Gib mir mal die Statistiken, wie viel die über Twitter reden, ne? Und dann wird er festgestellt, ja sind viele. Dann wird er feststellen, oh hier äh die Welt, die die Welt berichtet
darüber und denkt sich halt, das das Twitter grade ganz viel Aufmerksamkeit hat. Das twittert er ja auch.
Regelmäßig ne, dass gestern der, was weiß ich, der erfolgreichste Tag.
Für Twitter ever war ähm und und dieser Trump-Pol und haste alles nicht gesehen und Donald Trump hat jetzt schon wieder.
Soundsoviel Millionen Follower auf Twitter, weil die haben den Account wiederhergestellt mit null Followern, ne
und er hat jetzt schon wieder irgendwie zig zig Millionen und sowas dann denkt ihr immer so, boah hier also dann galt der sich halt an der an der Bedeutung von Twitter auf, aber er scheint nicht wahrzunehmen, dass,
diese Bedeutung daher also weißt du, das ist halt wie bei so einem Zugunglück, ja? Das ja.
Ist einen ganzen Tag rauf und runter in den Nachrichten und dann interessiert keine Sau mehr das Zugunglück. Und.
Ich glaube, dass der gerade nicht checkt, dass er ähm.
Dass er das Zugunglück ist, ne und dass dass es irgendwann die Leute langweilt und die werden einfach weggehen und werden sagen so, ich interessiert mich nicht mehr. Also ich ich habe auch, also ich
tatsächlich nutze ich jetzt eher meinen Masterdown Account, weil dieses Zugunglück halt langweilig wird.
Aber es liegt nicht daran, noch so ein bisschen die Crux,
du hast Recht, alle reden drüber mich nervt es auch mittlerweile.
Legen wir nicht zu viel Erwartungen an das Ganze. Also wir wir behandeln das Ganze wie als ob's irgendwie wir jetzt einen Politiker gewählt haben, der irgendwie unseren Staat richten soll. Ich meine, am Ende ist es ja immer noch Unternehmen und er kann ja machen und tun, was er will. Nur er muss ja nicht zwangsweise unsere Erwartung erfüllen.
Also ich.
Nur wir reden jeden Tag darüber und sagen, er muss dies und das machen und es muss dies und das können und sofort.
Ich hänge da noch nicht mal, also.
Niemand redet hier so, niemand redet hier so darüber, wie der nächste BMW aussehen soll oder so.
Ja wenn der Donald Trump drin sitzen würde, würden die den nicht kaufen.
Nein, aber also die natürlich, der kann machen, was er möchte und ich glaube aber, also das war jetzt wirklich eher auch ein Ausdruck von Mitleid, weil ich tatsächlich.
Anfangs das noch für.
Für nicht eine nicht nicht wirklich eine realistische Perspektive hielt, dass der dass es dem gelingt, diesen Laden um dann natürlich unabsichtlich zu ruinieren und jetzt denke ich ist es sehr viel.
Eher auf dem Horizont, dass er dass er, ne, ich meine, VW wirbt da nicht mehr.
VW weißt du welchen Markenschaden will VW denn noch abwenden? So ich meine,
Wenn die sagen, oh ja, von den Betrügern äh mit den Dieselmotoren, äh jetzt die neue Regel, wir werben nicht mehr auf Twitter. Sind wirklich so also ich ich denke tatsächlich, dass und vor allem, wenn solche.
Kunden mal abwandern und dann droht der denen noch, ne? Ich meine, die die können ja die kommen ja also die Gefahr ist doch, dass jetzt immer mehr Unternehmen,
mehr Nutzerinnen merken, buh, weißt du, das geht ohne Twitter geht genauso und ähm ich persönlich,
Markt Twitter schon, ja? Also ich ich es wäre ich fände es persönlich ganz okay, wenn das bleibt.
Ähm ich habe aber finde jetzt auch meinen.
Gefallen daran, also zumal, also ich finde meinen Gefallen an Mastodon, es ist tatsächlich, ähm kann man bei dieser Stelle noch mal auch erwähnen von Luca Hammer, den Feddyfinder, da kannst du halt wirklich einfach ähm.
Also wenn Leute in ihre Bio, ihren,
Masterdon Account schreiben, da gibt's im Prinzip zwei Formate, das eine ist zum Beispiel jetzt hier at Linuzifer at Chaos Punkt Social oder Chaos Punkt Social Slash äh athlezifa oder so was, ne, dann findet dieses Ding das automatisch,
mach dir sofort so eine Follow-Liste, ne? Und jetzt konnte ich halt auf meinem äh Account einfach diejenigen importieren, die schon auch einen Masterdown-Account haben und äh finde da.
Ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht die kritische Menge, um mich dort zu halten, aber auf jeden Fall ähm eine eine sehr gute, angenehme,
Mischung aus Leuten, die ich halt auch schon von Twitter kenne und das das wird jetzt nicht Twitter erledigen, aber das hat durchaus das Potenzial ähm.
Also ich ich sehe, es kommen, dass oder ich ich sehe es überhaupt erstmal im realistischen Bereich das Twitter tatsächlich von seiner,
Planlosigkeit,
am Ende zugrunde gerichtet wird. Ja ich glaube immer noch nicht, dass es passiert, aber es ist wenigstens mal im jetzt so in in eine realistische Option.
Die hätte ich ehrlich gesagt nicht gesehen,
Als es hieß, äh Elon Musk kauft Twitter gegen seinen gegen seinen eigentlichen Willen. Da habe ich nicht gedacht, dass der sie so blöd anstellen wird, das Ding innerhalb kürzester Zeit potenziell in den Ruin zu treiben.
Weil alles, was er er hat hier einfach nur nichts machen müssen.
Also,
Warum das ja so eine so eine so eine heiße äh Kartoffel ist alles, ne? Hier kommen ja zwei Sachen zusammen. Auf der einen Seite ist es nicht nur irgendein Social Network, sondern es ist
einerseits das Social Network, auf dem sich so bestimmte Eliten, ich sage nicht die Elite, aber bestimmte Eliten gefunden haben, ja, wo es um Ideen
geht, wo es um Meinungsaustausch geht, sicherlich auch um viel äh Gehate so, aber man kann ja auch dem Netzwerk nicht absprechen, dass,
dort nicht ganz vorne ist, weil da gibt's dann sozusagen kein anderen Netzwerke, die die mit der äh Geschichte groß für sich werben könnten und das ist auch der Grund, warum so viele daran
hängen. Ist auch der Grund, warum ich daran hänge,
Ganz klar, also das das für mich so ein bisschen der schon, schon immer der Spaß äh äh gewesen auf auf Twitter da einfach diesem äh weltweiten Meinungsdiskurs über im Prinzip
alle Themen der Welt,
beiwohnen zu können. Kannst ja irgendein Thema ausdenken, so bei YouTube findest du die Videos dazu, ja? Auch viel Opinian, aber so diese dieses schnelle sich über bestimmte,
Geschehnisse, Ereignisse und Ideen ähm hin und her abzustimmen und anderen Leuten beim Diskutieren zuzuschauen, dass es halt irgendwie nur äh das kann halt.
Derzeit nur so Twitter abbilden,
bildet derzeit nur Twitter so in der Form ab. Das Zweite, was noch dazukommt, ist, dass halt natürlich mit Musk jetzt äh der
zumindest bis vor kurzem potenziell äh reichste Mensch der Welt dahergekommen ist und gesagt hat so eine Firma, die in irgendeiner Form auch noch eine gewisse öffentliche Kontrolle hat über diesen Aktienmarkt
Ja, also da ist so so eine bestimmte Insanity zumindest über das Regulatorium Finanzmarkt in irgendeiner Form noch im,
Griff gehalten wird. Das hat er jetzt mit so dermaßen viel Geldaufwand äh auch noch ausgehebelt, dass dieses Unternehmen
in diesem Zustand, in dem es eben bisher war, also wirtschaftlich
wirtschaftlich fragwürdig so. Ähm vom Betrieb her sicherlich umstritten, aber auch von seinem gesellschaftlichen Wert her auch beliebt, dass er das jetzt einfach nimmt und so nach seiner Fasson irgendwie,
dreht und wir uns alle fragen, bist du nur grade nicht in der Lage, äh die
die richtigen Business-Entscheidungen zu machen, um das Ding zum Erfolg werden zu lassen? Oder geht's dir tatsächlich um etwas anderes? Geht's ja drum, dass du so im republikanischen Sprachrohr und irgendwie der der Krypto-Fans und und und Neurechten und so weiter zu zu drehen oder ist das auch nur eine Trollerei
oder oder bist du einfach so in App und so so bekloppt und und und von irgendwelchen Drohungen, die man noch nicht kennen, so zerfressen, dass du einfach wirklich nur noch durchdrehst und und und.
Gar keine Kontrolle mehr hast. Das sind, glaube ich, so die das sind so die beiden Pole, die sie jetzt alle so verrückt machen so, ne.
Ich würde vorschlagen, mach doch ein Twitter Paul. Dann wissen wir die.
Her damit.
Aber tatsächlich deine, was denkst du.
Es gibt ja sogar Studien, die ähm die zeigen, dass Tesla nicht in dem Maß im Kurs gestiegen wäre, wenn nicht er selber quasi mit Twitter das Ganze noch gepusht hätte. Also er hat's natürlich auch für sich als eigenes Werkzeug schon lange halt irgendwie benutzt.
Das war ja, das war mein ursprünglicher Tweet, für den ich ja der lag ich falsch. Äh habe ich ja gesagt, äh Kursmanipulation wird Twitter ist äh.
Elon Musks äh Spezialität und dass er das Ganze mit Twitter selbst macht, ist einfach nur ein lustiger Gruß aus der Küche. Er wird nicht kaufen.
Ich glaube, hätte ich geschrieben, er will nicht kaufen, äh wer der Tweet noch noch besser gewesen mit dem er wird nicht kaufen
hatte natürlich Abzüge der B-Note, aber äh also das das das auch also noch dazu eben jemand ist, der mit Kursen herum manipuliert. Ich wollte gerade nur mal sagen
wie weit Twitter gefallen ist, seitdem er wie weit Tesla gefallen ist, seitdem Maske Twitter gekauft hat,
aber Tessa ist heute, nur heute um 7 Prozent gestiegen. Erstaunste, ne.
Nur heute, 7 Komma 8 2 Prozent ist ist der Kurs von Tester hochgegangen an einem Tag.
Ja weil sie jetzt über ein äh Programm reden. Das ist sozusagen das, wo sie gerade hingetrieben werden.
Äh hat er natürlich auch über Twitter verbreitet, ne, aber also die diese also Tester ist einfach eine dermaßen volatile Aktie und das,
ist mir kann ich eigentlich auch nur erklären durch eine sehr kluge Öffentlichkeits.
Arbeit, weil das kann ja nicht sein, dass also das das Unternehmen schwankt wirklich um um also keine Ahnung, um ein Vielfaches, ne.
Hat doch alles damit, also das ist doch nicht dieser Kurs von Tessa entwickelt sich ja nicht normal, da sind doch die ganze Zeit irgendwelche äh
naja Leute am Werk, die sich freuen, dass das Ding rauf und runter geht und äh und sie damit jedes Mal gewinnen können oder nicht. Also sorry,
Vielleicht äh überschätze ich das jetzt, aber das ist doch nicht eine Aktie, die sich normal verhält.
Aktion hat gerade was getrieben ist durch,
Erhöhung durch Inflation, durch Krieg und Sofort, plus natürlich das grade auch, wie du schon das auf Tesla auch,
viele Reddit-User oder was auch immer, Leute drauf traden. Ich glaube, das erzeugt genau diese Vodafilität. Es ist jetzt nicht in so einem normalen ruhigen Fahrwasser trifft aber auf ganz viele Tec-Aktien zu. Also ich glaube, das ist ja einfach nur in diesem Basket von von all diesen Titeln halt irgendwo sind. Ich glaube, dass jetzt nicht Tesla spezifisch halt.
Sieben Prozent übrigens sind von gestern. Heute ist ja die amerikanische Börse.
Oh sorry.
Ja, muss auch mal danke sagen.
Also ich glaube darum bleibt es ziemlich spannend und wie gesagt, ich glaube eher, dass es entweder Richtung Pleite geht oder aber dass es irgendjemand dann eben abkauft für einen kleinen Euro äh oder US-Dollar. Was ich mir auch noch überlegt habe, was technisch gehen würde. Tesla können sie auch Twitter kaufen.
Rein technisch gesehen würde es funktionieren. Ich meine es hätte einen sehr sehr üblen Nachgeschmack aber es würde funktionieren. Ich meine er hat ja auch schon irgendwie die Solarfirma seines äh was war das deines Bruders oder so was gekauft? Also von daher warum soll es nicht da auch noch gehen.
Tesla sollte Twitter kaufen. War das gerade deine Vorschlag.
Zumindest würde ihm das so ein bisschen ein paar Schulden erlassen und so weiter. Aber ich glaube, dass wird dann als Letztes passieren.
Ja, also das sehe ich jetzt irgendwie auch gerade alles nicht, obwohl man sich ja schon gar nicht mehr wundert noch. Also es ist irgendwie alles so dermaßen absurd geworden
ich meine diese
beiden Pole, die ich davor hingestellt habe so und als Grund, warum das überhaupt alles so heftig diskutiert wird, auch von uns, ja, weil es ja einfach so eine Verunsicherung auch auslöst und auch äh,
noch weitergehende Fragestellungen aufwirft. Können wir vielleicht jetzt auch mal uns vielleicht von Twitter mal jetzt so ein bisschen,
und auch mal überlegen, in was für einer Zeit wir jetzt eigentlich gerade leben äh,
ob wir grade noch was Größeres beobachten,
Gibt ja auch noch ein paar andere äh Trends, die so mit dazukommen, ne? Also Facebook hat irgendwie äh viele Leute entlassen, Twitter hat viele Leute entlassen, also es ist nicht nur bei Twitter so, mag bei Twitter jetzt ganz spezifische Gründe haben
aber generell im ganzen Silicon Valley ist gerade so eine Entlassungswelle. Also man hat so das Gefühl, irgendjemand hat so mit einer Nadel äh in die heiße Blase äh piekst, ja, die jetzt nicht so eine.
Finanzbuble war, sondern vielleicht auch so eine Relevanz-Bubble,
war. Also das macht gerade es gibt,
so ein paar Auflösungserscheinungen bei Unternehmen und bei Strukturen.
Die bis vor kurzem glaube ich noch als weitgehend unangreifbar.
Techfirmen sind
die größten Unternehmen der Welt geworden so. Das ist irgendwie vollkommen klar, wenn wir irgendwie so die
50 größten Unternehmen der Welt anschaust, da hast du zwar noch den ein oder anderen Erdölproduzenten so, aber die ganzen Automobil äh Unternehmen und Klassiker so der siebziger Jahre
äh müssen sich doch deutlich weiter hinten einreihen. Während alles, was halt irgendwie die Technologie im Griff hat, Google et cetera. Das war halt irgendwie äh entsprechend hoch
eingeschätzt und das mag sich jetzt vielleicht grade ändern. Wie siehst du denn das so aus dieser Finanzperspektive,
oder welcher Perspektive auch du immer du hast oder die ist ja bei dir sozusagen mit mit drin.
Ich glaube schon.
Hab's mal äh jetzt vor Kurzem so gesagt, dass wir so ein bisschen das Ende vom Anfang sehen. Ich glaube, dass sich gerade tatsächlich äh etwas in mir zusammenrückt oder zusammen Recht zurechtrückt,
vom Gefühl her. Ich meine, du hast gerade schon gesagt, Facebook.
Verliert peu peu sozusagen, äh lässt der Glanz nach, sage ich mal. Ähm.
Twitter sehen wir, dass es auch zerbröselt und weiß, wenn's mal wenn's zerbröselt, dann wird's wahrscheinlich in verschiedene differenzierte Kanäle gehen. Die Leute gehen da irgendwie bei Reddit und sonst wo irgendwie unter und nutzen das dann weiter und wie weiter aufgesplittet,
über FDX gesprochen, Kryptowährung ähm zerfällt,
Finanzmarkt, die Zinsen werden angezogen, viele Startups das wird jetzt die nächste Welle sein werden sicherlich nicht überleben, weil sie keine Anschlussfinanzierung finden,
Aktienmarkt liegt jetzt auch eher mal ähm äh flach und Unternehmen müssen sich denn jetzt wahrscheinlich auf ihre Kernkompetenz irgendwie berufen und auf Kernprodukte irgendwie weiterarbeiten.
Daraus wird da sicherlich was Neues entstehen und die Frage ist halt, was wird daraus irgendwie Neues ihm entstehen. Wir erleben natürlich so ein bisschen,
dass alles irgendwie versucht wird zu kontrollieren. Also Apple geht jetzt runter bis irgendwie auf eigene Chips zu bauen, um äh da wirklich jeden einzelnen Prozessschritt und im im Griff zu haben und zu wissen, irgendwie wann mal was,
nicht und was es halt irgendwie kostet,
Augmented Reality steht irgendwie vor der Haustür, dass wir irgendwie auch in zehn Jahren unsere Smartphones nicht mehr haben und all das,
wird hier irgendwie was Neues übergeben. Die Frage ist halt, was wird das halt irgendwo sein? Das lässt sich glaube ich schon irgendwie beobachten.
Wenn ich mal San Francisco noch einen Satz in San Francisco gehe, ich mein die Stadt ist leergefegt,
Ich meine auch nach Corona ist dort niemand mehr. Weil also übertrieben. Also die Restaurants haben nur noch von donnerstags bis sonntags irgendwie offen. Natürlich sind sie dann ausgebucht, aber sie finden keine Kunden mehr für montags bis mittwochs,
weil irgendwie jeder im Homeoffice irgendwo sitzt.
Alle sagen, Amazone lässt zehntausend Leute, mal ganz ehrlich, Amazon er lässt übrigens rein mathematisch gesehen, jeden Tag 10.000 Leute, weil,
Leute händeringend, sich neue Teams oder neue Firmen suchen, weil sie's da nach einem halben Jahr nicht mehr aushalten,
Also das ist jetzt nicht nur, weil sie irgendwas einsparen müssen, sondern da wechselt jeden Tag 10.000 Leute.
Interessant bei Amazon, die zahlen ein doppelt das doppelte Gehalt im also von was ich EI programmiere ansprechen, das doppelte Gehalt im Vergleich zu Google oder zu zu ähm Apple.
Aber was die Programmierer dort sagen, ist es so ein bisschen so, als ob du Dreck an die Wand wirfst und das, was kleben bleibt, äh das wird dann schnellstmöglich irgendwie umgesetzt, dass mein erster Markt ist. Wäre man bei Google und bei Apple noch sagt, ja okay, man könnte es machen, aber vielleicht können wir's noch effizienter machen, dann dauert das alles so ein bisschen,
Interessant, dass man mit so viel Kosten, so viel Ineffizienz, trotzdem es schafft vielleicht irgendwie mit Produkten erst am Markt zu sein, um mir Geld zu verdienen. Ich meine, so ist ja irgendwie auch unter anderem irgendwie Alexa entstanden,
übrigens bis heute nicht geschafft hat, daraus wirklich richtig Geld zu.
Ganz im Gegenteil, ne. Also Alexa äh las ich gerade, wird jetzt so als eines der größten.
Einer der großen Failias gesehen überhaupt diese ne? Das ist nicht,
ist, daraus ähm etwas zu machen, was
mit anderen Worten bedeutet, die machen tatsächlich nur das, was draufsteht, nämlich,
Machen dir die Musik an, die du hören willst und äh
schaffen es nicht, dir noch irgendeine Scheiße zu verkaufen, nach der du gar nicht gefragt hast, äh was ich persönlich als Erfolg werte des der Produktkategorie, aber eben im wirtschaftlich offen, meine absolute Niederlage ist.
Ich meine, dadurch, dass die Zinsen jetzt nun mal gestiegen ist, man jedes Projekt rechnet sich natürlich, wenn ich irgendwie null Zinsen habe, so mit gestiegenen Zinsen muss ich nämlich jetzt dreimal rechnen,
Kredit dafür auf, ich muss Zinsen zahlen, ab wann kriege ich denn Geld zurück? Ab wann rechnet sich mein Projekt? Und das führt natürlich automatisch dazu, dass natürlich jetzt eben nicht jeder.
Entschuldigung, nie der Scheiß gemacht wird, sondern wirklich sich darauf zu konzentrieren, was ist für die Wirtschaft wichtig, was generiert halt eben nun mal Geld.
Und was ich auch glaube ich sehe und auch beobachte, ist, dass wir irgendwie zehn Jahre lang in Software investiert haben. Klar, es ist natürlich irgendwie billig. Es lässt sich gut skalieren und man verdient eine Menge Geld damit,
Ich glaube, dass wir in das nächste Jahrzehnt irgendwie übergehen, dass wir jetzt Projekte umsetzen, die halt wirklich wesentlich mehr Geld kosten, weil wir eben nicht Software bauen, auch noch, aber halt viel mehr Hardware,
Wenn wir jetzt sagen,
dieser ganze Green-Tech-Bereich, mein der Druck ist immer noch nicht groß genug, aber gibt's da schon viele Technologien, aber das kostet halt Geld, weil physisch was gebaut wird. Ich glaube auch, dass halt.
Investieren an sich auch ändern wird und die Renditen darauf übrigens dann auch nicht so hoch sind, weil klar Hardware bauen ist teurer als eben die Software zu bauen, die halt entsprechend zu äh zu skalieren. Und zum Schluss bleibt die Sache die Globalisierung. Wir versuchen jetzt irgendwie Wertschöpfungsketten irgendwie bei uns mehr aufzubauen.
Thematik bleibt mit mit Taiwan und China. Wenn da mal ein Angriff passiert, haben wir glaube ich eine ganz andere Probleme und auch das kostet natürlich mehr Geld. Aber ich glaube, so eine Schippanlage, die Insel hier in Deutschland bohrt, ist sicherlich nicht so effizient wie die, die TSMC Dame One Taiwan betreibt.
Aber im Endeffekt in dem ganzen System dazu, dass halt eben nicht mehr so hohe Renditen erzielt werden. Und das wird auch etwas irgendwie mit den Märkten machen und auch mit der Gesellschaft.
Ja, also wir haben sozusagen verschiedene äh Prozesse, die hier so,
gerade äh entwickeln. Auf der einen Seite so ein bisschen an Absinken der Silicon Valley Dominanz, auch wenn es sicherlich immer noch
bei weitem das dominanteste äh System ist und sicherlich auch nicht morgen schon tot ist. Ne, also selbst wenn sich da Dinge ändern äh
ist da ist ja noch noch lange keiner mal soeben auf äh von Platz 2 auf Platz eins vorgerückt.
Nichtsdestotrotz, das hatten wir ja anfangs auch schon erwähnt, es gibt eben auch äh interessante Contender, zumindest auf anderen Märkten, also wir haben ja auch schon, sagen wir mal, eine sehr äh westlich,
Brille hier, ne? Also wenn du sozusagen aus Russland, aus China äh oder überhaupt auch nur irgendwo aus Asien heraus, aufs Internet schaust, ähm Indien, dann dann gibt's da auch nochmal ganz andere Player, von denen wir noch nie was gehört haben, ne oder teilweise äh auch
das schon so wie
Alibaba äh und und solche äh Dinge, wo man auch hier mal schon was bestellt, weil's halt irgendwie überall ist, ne ähm aber dann eben parallel dazu eben dieser
ich sage mal die die Zurückhaltung bei der Globalisierung,
also dieser Traum von irgendwie
alles jederzeit weltweit verfügbar
klickst du dir hier, kommt innerhalb von 24 Stunden aus China geflogen, geht sofort just in time in deinen ganzen Produktionsprozess rein. Das ist jetzt irgendwie erschüttert durch Corona und dann nochmal erschüttert durch durch die neuen politischen äh Spannungen, eben nicht nur Russland, sondern eben
ne auch unter anderem diese äh Taiwan äh Frage, sodass das ja dann auch eine Neuordnung der Produktionsstandorte bedeuten kann. Das zeichnet sich ja auch teilweise schon ab.
Definitiv.
Was es angerichtet hat. Ich meine Amazon Microsoft und auf Facebook werden immer gesagt, dass sie so sind. Also die haben wenig Geld für irgendwie Hardware Dinge ausgegeben und mit Software hast du einen großen Return auf dein eingesetztes Kapital.
War das auch vor zehnjährigen Jahren mal so, aber jetzt ist übrigens nicht mehr so, also der Return on Ployd sagt man, also der das EBIT geteilt durch das Kapital, ähm äh wenn man so will,
War mal bei 70 Prozent die Kurde, die bei 20 Prozent, das heißt.
Amazon, wenn sie für zehn Milliarden irgendwie ähm Satellitenabschlussbasis kaufen oder wo ich seit Leben ins All schieße plus irgendwie eine Film äh ähm Pillenverpackung et cetera, das kostet ja alles Geld, finanziert aus dem Kernbusiness,
Aber es führt aber dazu, dass eben sehr breit wirst, aber eben auch nicht mehr so rentabel bist.
Glaube, das vergessen die Leute halt, dass eben diese Firmen auch zu riesengroßen Giganten worden sind, die aber auch massiv Geld an vielen Stellen verbrennen und jetzt auch ein Haufen stehen halt haben.
Es war lange Zeit okay, solange man mit dem Kern bist, das irgendwie Geld verdient. Ich meine, Amazon macht zwei Drittel des Gewinns irgendwie mit ABS halt. So wenn das aber jetzt ins Stocken kommt, ähm.
Et cetera bei Facebook, sieht man ja auch, klar, dann guckt jemand nochmal dreimal hin und sagt was, ich kaufe für zehn Milliarden irgendwelche Satellitenfirmen. Finden wir jetzt aber nicht so lustig.
Zumindest müssen wir uns keine Sorgen machen, dass Europa irgendwie äh den Platz 1 einnimmt. Ich glaube, da sind wir,
noch weit von äh entfernt in diesem ganzen digitalen Markt irgendwie nennenswert aufzuschließen. Da gibt's halt so ein paar
ja so ein paar Cronio wählen und das war's dann äh eigentlich im Wesentlichen.
Wird sich relativ wenig ändern, aber trotzdem sind wir natürlich Teil dieses ganzen
Prozesses und es ist um vielleicht auch mal so ein bisschen die netzpolitische Perspektive hier zumindest zum Ende nochmal ein bisschen mit reinzuholen
Stellen sich natürlich durch diese ganzen Veränderungen demnächst auch neue Fragen der
Regulierung und und und der Bedeutung auch einer einer globalen äh Ordnung. Was haben wir nicht hier,
nur mit Twitter, sondern auch so generell mit äh Netzen uns äh immer wieder gefragt so ja okay was denn hier mit Facebook, was sind hier mit,
Twitter und äh Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz und Hate Speech,
Rahmen und so weiter und immer diese permanente Frage zwischen ja okay was du jetzt hier freie Meinungsäußerung und was ist jetzt schon kriminell und und welche Juristriktion darf denn jetzt hier angewendet werden? Sagen wir mal
Es würde jetzt tatsächlich irgendwie Twitter äh kollabieren und auf einmal so ein Mast oder ein basiertes soziales Gesprächsnetzwerk äh
übernehmen, ja, wo dann sozusagen die Diskussion auf einmal auf auf tausenden äh Abertausenden von Servern stattfindet, wo irgendwie keine großen
Unternehmen dahinter stehen mit einer dicken juristischen Abteilung ja, sondern äh alle sind auf einmal unterhalb äh des Radars.
Und äh äh Gesetze greifen auf einmal äh äh nicht mehr auf der einen Seite, ja, also neue Fluchtorte ist so der sozusagen die eine Perspektiv,
die sich darauf ausmacht, aber auf der anderen Seite hast du's dann natürlich auch wiederum mit sehr viel weniger Zuverlässigkeit zu tun, weil du in so einem Wild-West
äh äh Netzwerk, wo äh wie kleine,
wieder das äh Sagen haben, ist natürlich mit auf einmal mit ganz anderen Gefährdungen zu tun hast
ich ich schweife so ein bisschen ab, aber das sind so äh alles so so Dinge, die sich auf einmal,
als Option äh eröffnen oder zumindest so Gesprächsgegenstand äh zu werden scheinen das äh noch vor kurzem irgendwie überhaupt nicht so richtig aufm.
Auf der Agenda war.
Du solltest ja gerade Europa wird er schwer. Ich glaube, würde man einfach nochmal in unserem eigenen Land bleiben, Deutschland. Ich also ich sehe habe da irgendwie sehr, sehr große Bedenken,
Dieses China-Thematik nochmal aufbringen. Ich meine, wir exportieren irgendwie jeden Furzen Feuerstein eben dann nach China halt. Wenn jetzt aber da mal der ähm China in in Taiwan eingreift
damit der Amerikaner sagen, so ab jetzt wird die Schiene hier boykottiert, liebe Deutsche. Auf welcher Seite steht ihr jetzt,
Werden sich Deutschen wahrscheinlich auf die amerikanische Seite schlagen und dann ist natürlich schlagartig vorbei mit Produkten, die wir irgendwie nach nach China äh exportieren. Ist natürlich auch schlecht für unsere irgendwie Wirtschaft.
Hinzu kommt auch nach wie vor irgendwie verlieren wir natürlich immer mehr ähm den den Anschluss,
Was ich in München gibt's irgendwie fantastisch Unternehmen, die irgendwie weiß ich, Kennfusionen irgendwie dran forschen. Ja, warum nicht mal Damian zehn Millionen Euro Ticket als Staat schreiben und was weiß ich zwei, drei Prozent von dem Unternehmen halt ähm nehmen und sagen, okay, wir versuchen immer so was nach vorne zu bringen. Machen die USA irgendwie riesengroß.
Somit kommen wir natürlich auch nicht vorwärts. Und diese ganze Autothematik hatten wir gerade auch,
Mein VW verschiebt jetzt nochmal irgendwie ihr ihr ähm Softwareprojekt um drei, vier Jahre, um irgendwie den Tesla auf den Markt zu bringen. Ja, weil wir nie gelernt haben, irgendwie oder zumindest dort in dem Bereich, im Autobereich irgendwie mit mit Software umzugehen, das ist ja wirklich eine ganz neue Denke.
Natürlich dann jetzt demnächst sagen, ja wir machen ein Auto-OS, ähm was dann irgendwie BMW, VW und gleichzeitig nutzen, ja, aber womit wo ist denn da noch der Wert? Dass der BMW einen schöneren Sitz hat, aber alle die gleiche Software haben? Weiß ich nicht.
Da bin ich auch ein bisschen äh skeptisch, was die Rolle von äh Deutschland angeht. Und das ist ja auch nichts als Absatzmarkt. Das ist ja vor allem auch eine Neuorganisation der Wirtschaft jetzt erforderlich äh mit China auch als ähm
ja als Quelle von Ressourcen und äh zu Arbeit et cetera. Ja.
Also Linus was denkst du wird das Internet überleben oder schalten wir es einfach ab.
Fangen wir mal mit Twitter an. Ähm.
Du weißt, dass wir da den Podcast einstellen müssen.
Kein Twitter mehr gibt oder wenn's kein In.
Kein Internet, wenn's Internet im Internet abgeschaltet ist, dann fällt sozusagen ganze Netzpolitik einfach flach. Licht aus.
Ein paar CD raus oder? CDs verteilt.
Ist viel zu digital.
Stelle nicht die Frage, ob das Internet uns mehr Probleme äh gelöst oder gebracht hat.
Das lässt sich auch schwer beantworten.
Ich finde diese.
Diese Aussicht, dass das mit der mit dieser schnellen Entwicklung und dem losen Geld äh jetzt tatsächlich massive,
oder spürbare Konsequenzen für diese äh Internetumgebung hat ähm.
Eine sehr interessante Aussicht. Das äh habe ich in dem.
In dem Ausmaß noch nicht so aufm Schieben gehabt. Man hört zwar immer, ja, ja, hier die ähm.
Big Tech, die müssen jetzt vorsichtiger sein, weil sie müssen jetzt mehr Zinsen zahlen auf das Geld, was sie verbraten ähm aber das was das tatsächlich für Konsequenzen haben wird finde ich ganz spannend. Das heißt ja jetzt eigentlich so diejenigen, die,
funktionierende.
Geschäftsmodelle haben, aus denen sie selber Geld generieren,
gehört so ein bisschen die Zukunft wahrscheinlich, ne? Da gehört Twitter jetzt nicht unbedingt zu.
Solche Leute wie Facebook, die genug Geld generieren, meinst du, oder.
Generieren die noch genug Geld? Ich weiß es nicht. Also wahrscheinlich schon, ne.
Noch verdienen sie einen Haufen ja.
Also das heißt, die haben also auf Pump finanzieren ist jetzt nicht mehr, meinst du in Zukunft.
Ich glaube alle die, die auf Pump finanziert haben, ich glaube die werden ein Problem haben. Dazu gehören natürlich eben nicht die die Facebooks dieser Welt äh logischerweise, die haben nicht gute Bilanzen,
die auf Pump was finanziert haben und irgendwie demnächst mal eine Anschlussfinanzierung brauchen und dann sagt boah jetzt müsst ihr aber statt ein vier Prozent zahlen für die kannst du natürlich dann irgendwie äh doch dann als Unternehmen möglichst schwerer werden. Also ich glaube,
Investieren sollte man schon nochmal definitiv genau in die Bilanz gucken.
Und in die Firmenstruktur und mal erzählen, wie viel Unternehmen da jetzt eigentlich drin sind.
Keiner wissen, dass eine letzte Frage noch, warst du äh ähm der Preis für den Twitter jetzt verbrannt wird, ne? Findest du den zu hoch oder zu niedrig.
Ähm das war irgendwie Aktienkurse um die 54 Euro rum. Tatsächlich das war aber noch bevor jetzt wie eine Weltkrise haben im Bereich Werbemarkt war mein Preis, das hätte ich sogar noch höher gewesen. Ich glaube der ging so Richtung sechzig siebzig ungefähr. Es passte eigentlich schon,
aber klar, ich glaube, wer die Aktie jetzt immer noch am am Markt während durch der Wert jetzt deutlich niedriger, weil natürlich auch Twitter betroffen wäre von den Werbegeldern, was das grade mir eingespart wäre. Ich glaube, da wird die Aktie jetzt auch deutlich tiefer halt.
Ein bisschen abgerutscht oder tiefer gerutscht. Was man auch in den Zahlen sieht, ne? Man sieht so ein bisschen diesen Corona-Effekt, man hat irgendwie,
vier, fünf Dollar mal verdient pro Nutzer, dann ging's mal irgendwie rauf, auch so ein bisschen nach Corona, auch mit den verbesserten Werbemechanismen auf dem B7 Dollar, was da die letzten Quartale jetzt bis Q 2, wo es übernommen wurde, wir auch Richtung 5 wieder abgeschrumpft ist. Man hat das halt auch schon in Zahlen gesehen.
Ist auch der Grund, warum Elo Mask gesagt hat, boah, jetzt habe ich da aber keine Lust drauf, weil.
Hätte es glaube ich lieber irgendwie gekauft, wenn die Aktie bei 20 gewesen wäre. Ich glaube, dann wäre es natürlich deutlich einfacher gewesen. Ich glaube, dann wäre der Druck für ihn auch nicht so groß gewesen.
Nö.
Da muss er jetzt durch. Da muss er.
Der muss jetzt durch.
So bestellt, das wird jetzt so gegessen.
Na ja gut, gucken wir mal, ob's nächste Woche Twitter noch gibt. Ich äh habe habe schon erste Zweifel äh gehabt zwischendurch. Aber na ja, mal gucken.
Glaubt ihr denn, das machst du dann irgendwie eine Zukunft hat oder meint ihr, dass es dann morgen auch wieder einschläft.
Also es gibt einen ähm interessanten Artikel von Frank Rieger ähm der den haben wir auch in den Shownotes für mehr und bessere Filterblasen. Wer im Prinzip sagt, ja ähm.
Äh
Hat im Prinzip gezeigt, äh dass es es ist einfach zu groß. Ja und dass die Idee vom globalen Dorf äh so ein bisschen falsch ist und dass es
potenziell vielleicht tatsächlich zurück in die kleineren Filterblasen gehen,
kann. Frage ist natürlich, das heißt noch lange nicht, dass es ein föderiertes äh Netz sein muss. Das kann ja genauso gut eine Plattform sein, die wieder die Mehrfilterblasen ermöglicht.
Ähm ich habe momentan den Eindruck, dass es in in Mastren,
grade sich ganz positiv entwickelt, aber ähm im Prinzip wusste der es ja so vorstellen.
Und diese Debatten gehen ja jetzt auch los. Alles, was ähm.
Hier in diesem Artikel, dem Elon Musk in Aussicht gestellt wurde, nämlich herzlich willkommen in einer Welt von Schmerz, weil du Content Moderation nicht richtig machen kannst.
Das lernen ja jetzt eine ganze Reihe Mastodon Adminas auch nochmal auf die harte Tour,
weil sie jetzt äh ihre Massedoninstanzen ne überlaufen, weil es jetzt äh ich meine es gibt ich habe bisher aufm Mastsedon noch keinen Spam.
Gesehen, was an der herausragenden Arbeit von äh Lea und Rix liegt, die aber davon berichten, dass sie sehr viel damit zu tun haben natürlich Mastodon Spam auch zu bekämpfen. Das heißt, durch diese Föderation
wird die die Kontrolle der unangenehmen Effekte.
Unbedingt einfacher. Sehen wir jetzt zum Beispiel bei E-Mail, ne.
Und man sieht jetzt schon diese Konzentrationstendenzen, dass alle auf eine Instanz wollen und nur wenige sagen, ich mache jetzt eine eigene oder ich bin bereit irgendeine zu nehmen, aber so.
Alles in allem, da wird wird's noch sehr, sehr viele Probleme geben und Schluckläufe und so, aber äh bisher ist die Entwicklung da ganz positiv, würde ich sagen. Jetzt müssen sich nur die ganzen
längeren Mastodon Insassen ein natürlich auch mit diesem schnellen Wachstum anfreunden. Wir sind ja ähm mitunter mal ganz gerne.
Ja kritisch, weil,
jemand gecrosspostet hat wie ich, ja. Ich habe seit 2018 Master on Account, aber ich habe da immer nur mein Twitter-Feed hingespielt oder häufig nur meinen Twitter-Feed hingespiegelt und nicht nicht täglich reingeschaut und das wird dann ähm.
Wird er nicht gern gesehen und äh da wäre da wird natürlich jetzt auch quasi so ein.
Gentrifiziert, ne und äh das da wird's jetzt auch also da wird da wird's eine ganze Menge Reibung auch wiederum geben. Aber insgesamt funktioniert das super.
Also ich ich denke erstmal.
Ist zwar ähnlich. In vielerlei Hinsicht hat sich viel bei Twitter äh abgeguckt, verhält sich halt äh in vielerlei Hinsicht ähnlich. Ist aber sozial.
Noch was anderes und wird vermutlich auch was anderes bleiben.
Absolut. Das ist aber auch nicht schlimm, ja? Also das ist ja, das ist ja.
Damit auch nicht, ob ich damit auch nichts sagen wollte, dass es ich sage nur, dass.
Die Erwartung, dass jetzt das sozusagen das nächste Twitter ist, so die die teile ich äh nicht. Das ist eigentlich das, was ich damit äh zum Ausdruck bringen möchte. Es ist äh
schön, dass ähm Aufmerksamkeit geschaffen wird für so ein wahres
ist ja im Prinzip wieder so ein so ein alter Global Village.
Im Sinne von äh aus der Zeit des Global Village, ja, wo sich das Internet sozusagen als das globale Dorf äh äh verstanden hat, wo sozusagen alles voll mit netzbegeisterten Aktivisten waren und sozusagen die,
große Öffentlichkeit nach außen vor war und äh es gab ja auch immer wieder solche Momente, ne, also so Schübe, es gibt
jeden Tag mehr neue User, als es vorher insgesamt User gab. Das gab's irgendwie im Usnitz. Das gab's dann irgendwie mit AOL und so weiter. Also das waren alles solche Prozesse, die immer wieder kamen. Dann durch das Web durchforen äh äh et cetera, Facebook hat es äh auch noch mal so gebracht
immer so die Pioniere so ein bisschen äh von ihrem eigenen Erfolg auch zur zur Seite gefegt werden, wenn irgendwas mal wieder populär geworden ist
Das wird sicherlich auch äh Mast oder ein gewisser Hinsicht äh äh
erwarten und ich denke auch, dass äh es gibt Teile auch genau diese diese Bedenken, ne, dass also Content-Moderation ein richtig krasses Thema wird und dann natürlich dann in nächster Hinsicht auch
die Verantwortung und auch die juristische Verantwortung dafür, ne? Also was ist jetzt, wenn du dir so einen auf deiner Mast oder eine Instanz halt irgendwie so ein Neonazi äh eintrittst, der dann irgendwelche Terrorankündigungen macht? Oder es wird halt irgendwie äh problematisches äh Material äh veröffentlicht, ja und äh du weißt schon worauf ich hinaus will. Also das.
Das sind alles solche Effekte äh für die es dort noch äh zurecht gar keine Antwort gibt, weil dafür ist es halt eigentlich gar nicht gemacht. Gemacht
ist es auch in seinem ganzen Design für sozusagen Twitter.
Äh also Like, Twitter, aber für lokale Communities. Äh allein schon diese Entscheidung für einen Server
ist ja mehr als nur eine technische Entscheidung. Es ist ja auch eine kulturelle Entscheidung. Es ist also auf der einen Seite ist es eine kulturelle Entscheidung mit in
in was für ein Nest setze ich mich da eigentlich? Was sind da für andere Leute? Mache ich mir einen Account bei True Social, ja nee eher nicht irgendwie, weil es ja alles solche durchgeknallten Marger äh Heads, was soll ich da, ja? Äh,
hänge ich jetzt auf Caocial äh ab, okay, weiß ich in etwa so ja Friedensbewegte äh Nerd Community
Das ist dann sozusagen mein lokaler Bereich. Möchte ich dann aber mit anderen Leuten reden, dann muss ich meinem Entnahme gleich wieder so einen äh E-Mailschwanz hinten dran äh hängen und äh kommuniziere halt auch,
klar irgendwie so, ich funke jetzt mal woanders hin. Das mag technisch derzeit so noch nicht anders
lösbar zu sein, so aber dieses Fediverse wird sich natürlich dann auch
äh nicht überall gleich verhalten, weil äh die einen zensieren so, die anderen machen so
die einen haben technische Probleme so, die anderen haben diese vielleicht nicht. Die einen legen Wert auf bestimmte administrative Eigenarten und bei denen
was weiß ich irgendwie Sprachpolizei äh eine größere Rolle. Bei anderen ist es vielleicht eher äh.
Wie im richtigen Leben auch.
Ja ja, genau. Wie im richtigen Leben,
Jedes Dorf hat seinen Depp und so weiter, aber aber das ist es dann halt auch, ne. Während Twitter eben so dieser knallharte, zentrale Ort ist, wo man versucht hat, irgendwie Regeln zu finden für alle und zwar global weltweit,
Was vielleicht auch in sich schon mal ein bisschen gescheitert ist bisher, aber zumindest wurde es halt auch mal versucht und du hast natürlich dort einen Ort,
wo alle dann wiederum mit demselben Et-Name
ich bin den selben Namen, aber mit dem selben mit derselben Konstruktion sofort auch in jede Diskussion mit reingeworfen werden können. Nicht, dass man das immer toll findet, aber es war halt zumindest möglich und es hat ja auch interessante äh Sachen eröffnet, gerade weil du eben
alle Communitys ohne Weiteres zusammen äh bekommen hast. Also da wird sich das wird sich glaube ich noch so ein bisschen,
aussortieren müssen, was wofür wirklich äh geeignet ist. Beides hat sein äh seinen Anspruch, beides hat so seinen äh seinen Wert.
Ähm und ähm ja ich bin gespannt, wie sich das äh auscast und ich bin auch selber äh natürlich am Rätseln,
wie ich mich dort am besten positionieren kann, weil ich natürlich auch keinen Bock habe auf zu viele Netzwerke zu schauen. Also das ist halt einfach,
auch eine Überforderung, uns auch immer die Frage wie kommunizierst du jetzt da wohin, ja? Kommuniziere ich da jetzt sozusagen irgendwo im an okay, produziere ich denn.
Bin ich dann mit mit meinem Account, den ich dann auf dieser Instanz habe,
rede ich da sozusagen als eine Person dieser Community oder rede ich so als eine globale Person oder brauche ich mehrere Instanzen, ja, ist meine internationale Identität und meine
in den dann nochmal was anderes als irgendwie meine private, netzbewegte Identität.
Muss man rausfinden. Ist äh derzeit noch offen. Also von daher die Frage, wie kann sich das entwickeln? Das wird das wird die Zeit
bringen. Es hat auf jeden Fall ein paar technische Herausforderungen. Es hat auf jeden Fall auch ein paar soziale Herausforderungen. Aber ähm auf der anderen Seite,
wenn ein Twitter A komplett wegexplodiert, wird, glaube ich, der Bedarf nach einem unmittelbaren Twitterersatz sehr groß sein.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das dann vollständig von diesem Fettiverse aufgefangen werden würde.
Hm
Aber es gibt ja auch einen Grund, denke ich mal. Ich meine, jetzt ist doch die die Chance und die Zeit so groß wie noch nie, dass jetzt Facebook und Co ja auch ein Twitter bauen könnten. Tun sie aber offensichtlich ja nicht. Es wird ja auch einen Grund haben.
Ja weil es vielleicht noch nicht so weit ist, aber vielleicht sitzen sie ja schon dran. Also weißt du ja nicht. Also das das ist sehr wohl so, ne. Das das das könnte halt sein, ne.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so sein wird, aber es könnte auf jeden Fall so sein, weil das natürlich eine Riesenchance ist
da äh twitter irgendwie den Teppich unterm Boden wegzuziehen, ne? Und wenn du dann äh auch noch die Technologie hast, mit der du dann diese Skalierung bringen kannst, dann ist es halt was wert. Ich meine, Tweets stehen irgendwie auf Milliarden von Webseiten
und werden permanent irgendwie entkludet und sind sozusagen
Teil des Web-Contents auch, ja. Allein was das schon für eine Grundlast auf diesem System erzeugt ist, das wirst du irgendwie mit keinem Fediverse so äh erzeugen können und das ähm ja, das ist es
wird auf jeden Fall nochmal sportlich werden, was dabei rauskommt.
Die Entwickler die sagen mal diese ganzen Tools intern gebaut haben bei Twitter oben irgendwie in der Community Dinge zu moderieren, wegzuklicken, zu löschen und so weiter. Das das fehlt dem dem Master Donyo logischerweise auch noch, wenn es denn da auch zunimmt.
Also es ist ähm vielschichtig.
Da gibt's übrigens aber da gibt's ja einen sehr äh schönen äh äh Aufsatz noch von Cory Doctor Road zu, der sich äh auch damit ein bisschen auseinandersetze. Der der im Prinzip den das Argument bringt, na ja dieses Netzwerkeffekte,
die Facebook und Twitter groß gemacht haben. Die sind halt auch äh.
Ja Herr Erbarmungslos in die andere Richtung, ja und er endet beendet diesen Aufsatz mit, der ist jetzt gerade mal hier in Typ L übersetzt und dann passierte etwas. Mark Zuckerberg machte sich Sorgen.
Um den Verlust von Nutzern und Beschluss, dass wir alle als beinlose, wenig Polygonkartoons in einem Meterversum leben sollten
dass niemand nutzen wollte, nicht einmal die Facebook
Mitarbeiter, die es aufgebaut hatten. Twitter wurde von einem übermütigen Milliardär mit kurzer Aufmerksamkeitsspanne aufgekauft, der anfing herauszuziehen, um zu sehen, wann das System umfallen würde. Und.
Wurden wir alle von den fallenden Blöcken erdrückt.
Dienstleistungen waren so weit heruntergefahren worden, dass die meisten von uns kurz davor standen ohnehin zu kündigen, weil der gesamte Überschuss von uns,
und den gewerblichen Nutzern auf die Unternehmen übertragen worden war. Als die Dinge nur noch ein wenig schlechter wurden,
begannen Werbekunden und Nutzer zu kündigen, sodass das lang verzögerte Myspacing von Facebook.
Von Twitter begannen rest in. Äh war halt auch ein,
Social Network äh das äh anfangen. Äh ja irgendwie relativ schnell.
Alter, habe ich noch nie von gehört.
Auch noch nicht von gehört, aber äh Koi Doktor hat davon gehört. Ich habe auch ich,
er schreibt von BOISing, aber und das Wort gibt's nicht, deswegen habe ich äh den BBO Social Never vielleicht gab oder sowas. Aber er, ne, er ähm.
Ich denke die Netzwerke fegt in die andere Richtung ähm und er beschreibt nämlich auch, dass das der entscheidende Punkt war, der Facebook ähm.
Erfolg ausgemacht hat oder Facebooks schnelles Wachstum, dass sie so einen MySpace Importer nämlich hatten und
so konnten sie dann wenn du sagtest, ach du bist bei Myspace, ja guck mal hier Facebook, sieht schöner aus und wenn du uns jetzt eben wieder ein Passwort gibst, dann holen wir eh alles rüber und und integrieren das in unseren äh in unsere Wurst hier. Und äh genau das,
funktioniert ja mit dem Feddyfinder jetzt. Und damit kann äh so was vielleicht potenziell doch ganz schnell gehen.
Ja leider zieht er nicht alles äh rüber, was da gerne rübergezogen äh hätte.
Ja du kannst ihn mehrmals äh ausführen. Also wenn dann irgendwann alle bei Twitter nur.
Nee, aber der holt keine Listen.
Doch das geht auch, du kannst die Listen exportieren.
Es wird ganz schnell entwickelt. Da sitzen die Tesla-Ingenieure und gucken und sagen.
Na gut. Leute, wollen wir das vielleicht an der Stelle mal ähm,
Die Diskussion so ausklingen lassen, weil ich denke, wir haben jetzt sehr viel Food for Sard hier ausgegeben und ihr merkt sicherlich auch, wir sind auch selber da noch so ein bisschen auf der Reise.
Und ein wenig erschlagen von der Geschwindigkeit der äh Ereignisse und ja guck mal was da als Nächstes geschieht.
Wollte gerade zum ersten Mal auf Social gehen, aber es funktioniert gar nicht bei mir. Ich weiß nicht, ob die down sind oder ob ähm ob ich einen Content-Blocker habe, der das wohlweißlich verhindert.
Also bei mir steht auch Access The Night, also keine Ahnung. Das darf man wahrscheinlich nur in den USA benutzen oder so.
Social. Nee, mein mein DNS äh ja, okay, in Ordnung, super. Also hier ist alles dicht. Ist alles gut gemacht.
Daniel vielen Dank fürs äh Dabeisein und äh deine spannenden Schilderungen aus der Finanzwelt.
Vielen Dank, hat Spaß gemacht.
Immer wieder eine, glaube ich, sehr wertvolle Erweiterung unserer Perspektiven. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Ja, ich finde es generell es ich finde vor allem, es ist eine eine unterschätzte,
und oft auch finde ich zu Unrecht ausgelassene Perspektive, auf die Welt auch mal so aus so wirtschaftlichen,
Perspektiven zu blicken, ja? Weil einfach weil,
Weil wir eigentlich in einer Welt leben, wo das wo dem generell eigentlich viel Bedeutung beigemessen wird, ne, Geld. Äh da,
da interessiert sich ja eigentlich jeder drunter, nur so in so einer gesellschaftlichen Debatte will man das immer nicht so richtig
und versteht dann aber auch in der Folge meist nicht, wie denn eigentlich die ganzen Zusammenhänge, die Machtzusammenhänge äh et cetera und die Incentives, die da äh sich dahinter verbergen,
man die auch irgendwie richtig äh ins Hirn kriegt und teilnehmen lassen kann an dieser ganzen Debatte, oder.
Absolut. Ich glaube klar, Geld ist irgendwie der Treiber und was einem logisch erscheint, äh auch vielleicht gesellschaftlich muss dann eben nicht so passieren, wie du gerade sagst. Also Geld ist äh Incenti für vieles und.
Manchmal Dinge aber raus, die dann vielleicht nicht so viel Sinn machen.
Manchmal nicht unbedingt der schlechteste Incentive, weil wir ja letzten Endes auch mit einer guten Politik genau an der Schraube dann wiederum interessant äh drehen kann, um die Dinge dann auch an die richtige Richtung äh zu lenken, wenn man da nur dran denkt. Und wenn man sich halt der Zusammenhänge auch bewusst ist.
Zur richtigen Zeit an der Schraube dreht und nicht zu doll dreht, ne? Man kannst du dir auch dann wieder in die andere Richtung übertreiben, aber ja.
Genauso. Aber in Deutschland sind sie jetzt ganz schön alle am am Zittern zum Beispiel, dass die USA jetzt irgendwie angefangen haben so erneuerbare Energiebatterieproduktion und so weiter äh zu fördern bis äh,
bis der Arzt kommt so und ja dann kommt der Elon Musk und sagt so oh ja nee, da bauen wir doch keine Batteriefabrik in Brandenburg,
Und alle so Hilfe na gut, lass uns das äh Fass nicht auch noch aufmachen. Also nochmal danke äh Daniel, ich denke wir machen Kasten zu, stimmt's? Linus.
Machen wir.
Machen wir. Das war äh Logbuch-Netzpolitik 446 und ich weiß, wir waren ein bisschen äh unregelmäßig äh in der letzten Zeit. Das äh hat tausend Gründe. Die äh Thema ist, aber äh ne.
Ja, dafür hast du jetzt Zeit. Bis zur nächsten Sendung. Ja, kommt dann.
Wenn er so lange hält.
Wenn du das lange hältst. Wenn nicht, sagen wir euch als erstes Bescheid. Nichts ist schneller als Podcast. Bis dann. Tschüss.